哈喽 同学们 大家可以听到我说的话 可以给笔记本本天发要死了 喝起了 虽然给不了 但是笔记本本也会放 但是直播 因为直播都是最新研发的 都不一样
你如果总是看 会放 看到过去 嗯 好 大家可以听到 可以扣给 可以听 可以听到 过去吧 开一下啊 可以听到
这个非常好
然后我今天有点卡 卡了鞋子
嗯 应该是眼网的
因为我的
啊 我卡了
现在这么湿
啊 我把梯子关了
应该是开了
好 再见的同学们
再看一下
现在不开了
现在呢
是不是
我关了什么东西啊
咯 同学们 现在还卡吗
我又进来了啊
怎么又显示的暂停
因为我点了暂停了呀
这么简单的问题
因为我刚才点了 点暂停了
还卡
我已经退出去重新进了一遍了
还卡吗
其他同学卡不卡
好了吧
嗯 现在应该是好了
因为刚才我开了梯子了
可能我开了梯子
再开那个小合同他就会卡
然后我把梯子关了
又重新开那面小合同应该就好了
好了 太好了
不卡就行
那咱们就聊个一分钟
准备开始
好的
我把大家的这个互动区
我看看他怎么放一下
就是大家可能会经常看到我往这边看
是因为我在看你们的那个互动区
我有两块屏
这边有一个竖直的屏
然后这边有个横直的屏
大家如果经常看我直播的话
你应该知道我这边是有一块屏的
好的 正常了
那就好
好的 开始今天的表演是吧
看看那个同学给我发了一个跳舞的表情包
行了 咱就开始了
然后咱们的这个助理老师给还没有进到教室的同学们发一下
然后群里面也at一下大家
因为有个同学可能忘记今天要上课了
所以每次我都尽量的多通知大家几次
然后今天我们主要讲TVC
因为很多同学特别想学TVC
本来我今天是打算讲点别的
因为最近不是skill比较火吧
然后前两节课也讲了两遍skill了
但是有个同学人说老师我还想学skill
但我觉得如果再讲skill的话大家就有点受不了了
天天都是skill我都快长成skill了
那如果大家这种感觉的话
今天的咱们就依然有skill
但是咱们就不讲再去做短剧慢剧的skill了
如果想看短剧慢剧skill怎么去训练
或者是短剧慢剧怎么去搓的
这个同学你可以看一下之前的回放
如果是刚报名的同学
那今天咱们就讲一个之前没讲过的一个方向
叫做TVC
好
你来了
人伪生前
今天有点邋遢
确实今天因为不拍摄嘛
我也没有化妆
然后头有点油
大家凑合看看就得了
反正也都是中灯了
是不是
好
那咱们就准备开始了
我先在开始之前呢
问大家一下
我们有多少同学是今天
或者是本次刚刚报名的同学
如果之前没有听过我的社群课的同学
大家扣一个0
如果之前已经听过的同学
大家扣一个1
好吧
Skill还真不行
待会我让你看一看你就知道行不行了
Skill不行
有可能是你训练的Skill不太好用
ok
当然了如果你想做非常精致的影片
且想成本低一点的话
还是建议手搓
因为如果你想成本最低最低可控的话
那肯定是手搓来的比较的便宜一点
因为Skill你在初学的时候一用不好
用好了是比较省成本的
用不好了的话呢
你不小心一百多块钱
几百块钱就出去了
是吧
ok 外中心同学
你可以自己好好的训练一下
不一定我训练的和你训练的是同一种质量
好吧
ok 那咱们就先说到这里
首先呢我先来说一下
就是咱们开课之前
我先来说一下两件事
第一件就是介绍一下咱们的社群主要是
咱们的社群主要是怎么学习的
那第二件事呢就是我来说一下课堂纪律
首先呢我先来讲一下咱们的课堂纪律
那课堂纪律其实就是一句话
对吧做一个有素质的社会主义接班人
咱们呢有好交流有好沟通
我相信每位同学我们在线下见面的时候
不管是同学和老师也好
还是同学和同学也好
大家见了一面都是非常有礼貌的中国人
对吧
但是在网上可能有一些人说话就开始不负责任了
开始觉得我不用这个
不用考虑后果了
然后说出来一些非常不礼貌的话
这里我想跟大家说的是
那老师给大家进行的是一个非常真诚的分享
你们在
不能说全世界吧
在国内你应该是看不到第二个能像我一样
每一次直播都全新备课
全新研发
讲本周最新的东西的老师了
所以不管你有没有比我更好的方法
更好的效果
请不要抬杠
第二呢就是
各位同学
老师讲课的这个节奏也好
规划也好
我是有我的经验在里面的
所以大家不要说
这个觉得自己是这个宇宙的正中心
就是老师
你赶紧讲干户
我要看时操
你现在不许讲这个了
你如果说这个的话
我就当没看见
好吧
大家互相尊重
老师这样讲肯定是我自己的道理的
那在我的社群课里面
是没有那种割韭菜行为的
所以大家不用担心说
是不是老师讲的特别浅
然后后面让我们再报个什么什么
首先呢
我确实是有线下系统班
但是我绝对不会把我的社群课当做一个割韭菜的途径
这个大家不用担心
在我的课里我也不会上任何的链接
OK
这是一个
还有就是群内
就是大家在这个互动区要友好交流
不要互相吵架
有的时候老师我觉得老师说的对
我觉得老师说的不对
吵起来了
这种事情也发生过
因为咱们现在社群里的同学人数比较多了
所以大家保持友好交流
好
那么接下来我来用30秒的时间
把我们这个社群课大概的介绍一下
因为有些同学是刚刚报名或者是来试听的
那我来说一下我们的社群课有什么东西
刚才我也介绍了
咱们每一周都会有一个两节直播课
第一节课就是我来给大家讲的一个知识的分享
每一周都会有不同的案例的实操
大家可以看到我们到目前为止已经把
慢剧短剧设计品牌设计对吧
IP设计很多都给大家讲过了
包括很多软件新出的一些功能
每一周我都会全新备课讲全新的东西
比如说某个软件更新的一些新功能
接下来下个月肯定就是CNAS2.5了对吧
之前像LibTV的导演台
还有Lover的Brand Kit品牌套件
我都给大家在最新更新的那一周
就会给你们非常详细的讲出来
并且做很精美的案例
OK 那么这是每周的第一节课
我们主要是以干货分享为主
那第二节课呢
我们主要是来进行一个知识的答疑
大家平时在做的时候学习的时候肯定有很多的卡点
在遇到卡点的时候呢
你就可以在我们第二次的这个
每周的第二次的直播课里面
在前15分钟进到教室给老师把问题打出来
然后老师会接下来在后续的一个多小时里面
给大家一个一个的现场实操进行解答
注意我们的社群是没有任何在群内的
或者是老师的一为一答疑服务的
因为这个确实已经非常非常便宜了
是一个公益性质的这样的一个课程
老师确实也没有办法做到给大家一为一指导
但是我们能做到的就是在直播的时候
现场给大家进行指导
那注意进到群里的同学呢
这个报的年费的可以进啊
如果今天视听同学是进不了群的
这里有说一下
但是今天所有课程的回放直播
还有我们的材料都可以给到所有视听的同学啊
那么还有一点就是大家进到群里之后
是禁止加好友的禁止发布任何引流的
或者教程类的信息啊
这个老师已经跟大家说过了
一经发现的话我们是直接艺术群了解不退费的啊
这里跟大家提前说一下
所以所有的群规我们都会提前的说清楚啊
OK 那这个就是我们的社群课顶内容
大家如果今天试听也可以听一下我们今天的课程
质量好不好
呀 这谁给我来了个
谁给我打上这个音了
OK 给它关掉
好的 那这里我们来说一下就是
刚刚说到这个社群了嘛
如果还没有报的同学呢
今天如果觉得听起来不错
也可以考虑一整年的陪伴和学习
好 那我们就开始今天的内容了
大家有任何问题的话呢
也可以在公屏里问
当然我一般不会去乱打断我的上课节奏
我看到了的话
如果你很着急啊
这个问题
你的助理老师也可以直接给你去回复
那如果说不着急的话
就等待会我把干货讲完了
会专门给大家留时间来问问题的
好吧
好 那个同学啊
老师不是猴不是你点什么
我就能立刻讲什么的
大家如果都特别想学什么东西
可以在群内一起反馈一下
如果反馈的同学很多
那我会考虑在下一节课的时候去讲
好吧
嗯
你以为是你的
不服就干
我没有那么没素质
好
OK
行
那当然不是说你没素质啊
之前有同学还以为我在骂他
不是这个意思
我在开玩笑哈
OK
那咱们就开始今天的这个内容了
首先呢我们来说一下
今天我们来学TVC
我上前几天上个星期发了一条TVC的一个教程
然后呢评论区有一堆人
应该是咱们社群的小伙伴们
就开始问老师下节课去贵求讲TVC啊
然后我说好吧那就
争得大家的同意啊
咱们就开始讲这个TVC
都是大家特别想学的是吧
所以今天呢我会从这几个角度来讲
注意哈我之前是教大学生的
所以我的习惯是什么呢
我不会像那种传统的培训班里的老师
上来就给你教操作啊
操作咱肯定会学的
这个大家不用担心
不会说我现在给你讲一堆理论
然后操作放到系统课里让你教前学
不是的哈
今天咱们肯定是会讲操作的
但是我会将大家啊
我会对待大家
像对待科班的大学生一样去教
我希望大家能够掌握一些
你必备的一些理论认知啊
因为没有理论认知
你学一堆操作
可以说毛用没有啊
所以前面的这些理论的搭建
我认为是非常重要的
所以也不长啊
我大概跟大家说一下
这个工业化的流程是什么样子的
大家如果去做怎么样呢
高产能低成本的
把我们的TVC梳理出来
那今天的课上呢
其实我会教大家
两种做TVC的方法
其实跟上一期的
这个流程是类似的
但是我们的案例是完全不一样的
那今天第一波呢
我会先教大家
如果用Skill快速的去生产TVC
那第二波呢是我会教大家
如何去手挫整个流程
当然如果说老师
我想从视听语言开始学
我想成为影视大师啊
这一节课是实现不了的
请你学我的系统课啊
这个不是说我故意不跟你讲
这一节课真的讲不完
它实现不了你想要的那个效果
但是今天呢
我们可以教会大家
用LibTV去制作
通过这个Skill来完成TVC
同时呢
我还会教大家如何
在没有Skill的状态下
自己把整个流程走下来
并且把你的流程训练成一个可奉用的Skill
这个是咱们今天课里面最主要的东西
然后呢
我也会给大家去看一个
我认为做的还不错的一个账号
变现的效果也还不错的账号
可以给大家提前看一下
那这个账号我也有关注
它其实是一个客金账号
实话说它肯定是有流量投放的
比如说我们可以随便打开一个它的视频
叫零镜AIGC
数据看起来是不是还都不错
是吧
我们随便打开看一下它的数据
好
我为什么说它是一个投流账号呢
大家看一下旁边这个数据就知道
它的点赞是2.2
然后呢收藏是273
那很明显收藏量比点赞量低了太多
这就是一个非常明显的投流账号
但是它的这个点赞数据以及评论数据
已经足以支撑它养活一个团队
并且变现非常好了
OK
那真的有可能
如果它的更新频率上来的的话
它一个月的变现
有可能是高达几百万以上的
所以呢
我也希望大家把今天的这个内容
跟下来自己掌握
甚至训练出来一个自己专属的AI TVC广告制作的一个skill
OK
那这个就是我待会给大家可以去详细的我们插一下这个账号
老师的口头禅
老师不是猴
对呀
我特别不喜欢啊
就感觉把我当猴了
老师给我蹦一个
老师给我唱一个
来我这种感觉啊
非常不适是吧
引起了这种勾起了我小时候
亲戚来了之后
我妈让我跳个舞的不良回忆啊
好
OK
那我们就开始今天的这个内容了
在开始之前呢
我会给大家讲一点点的理论啊
千万不要嫌烦
好吧
OK
好
那么接下来呢
很多同学还不认识我
我大概的说一下啊
那大方老师目前全要有100多万的粉丝
是一名AIGC教育博主
那么我在教育这行已经深耕了10年的时间了
在AIGC教育这行也深耕了将近三年的时间
不是将近啊
已经有三年的时间了
因为我是从2023年的3月开始的
那从那个时候到现在我差不多亲自并且带团队研发超过了37套课程
且没有任何一套课程是在割韭菜啊
所有的课程全部都是非常良心非常干货的课程
OK
所以大家今天听到的我的每一句话都是经过了十多年讲课积累下后得到的一个结果
包括大家学到的AI相关的知识也是我用AI差不多用了三年多的时间得出了一个非常
我认为是非常短的一个路径大家很快就能够上手的一种方法
好 那么我除了自己的努力之外我的学生现在已经遍布各大互联网的公司了
比如说大家现在用的微信的UI设计师
然后还有这个TikTok抖音的UX设计师以及这个QQ音乐这个网易游戏
网易游戏等等等等很多的设计师都是我手把手带出来的徒弟
包括我自己也带着团队拿过四项级的国家级的大奖了
包括中华出版 中华优秀出版物 中国出版政府奖等等等等
大家都可以在豆包里查得到的 你们可以自己去查一下
好 那这些话咱就不多说了
咱们主要开始学习今天的干货
当然了如果有同学你们有系统学习的需要也可以去问助理老师了解我们线下每个月只开一期的系统课程
ok 好 那么接下来我们就进入到今天的第一个板块
那么很多同学以为要做广告了 是不是 上手 老师给我个提示词
其实我认为最蠢的事情就是找别人要提示词
当然我这个话一说出来之后下课之后这些同学瑟瑟发抖 老师我想要提示词但是我不好意思张口了 你说我蠢
我的意思不是说你不可以要别人的提示词 而是你无脑每次要了别人的提示词就知道复制粘贴的同学
那如果说你要了提示词你又知道自己分析一下底层逻辑 那我觉得没有任何的问题 对吧
好所以呢 在真正动手打开软件之前咱们要了解一下TVC广告的一个流程是什么
那我首先来说一下TVC是一个什么东西啊 那最早的时候呢我们其实管TVC传统意义上的叫做电视广告
好 现在还有人看电视吗 同学们 现在还在每天打开电视的同学 投影也算啊 扣个一 好吧 我看了多少同学还在看电视
嗯 对刚刚那个就是课金了 但是不影响他变现啊 对吧 广告客户他不管你课没课金啊
OK 现在只有两个同学看电视了 是吧 其他同学连电视都不看了
我呢现在会看投影 但是我看的是智能电视 是吧 现在大家看到大部分都是智能电视
但是我们有的时候会打开电视 爱奇艺也好 它会有一个贴片广告放在视频的最前面 对吧
那么像我小时候 我是90年生的 我10岁之前电视上只有20多个台 如果我没记错的话
可能都不到20个啊 那么那个时候咱们在获取信息 获取媒体信息的这种途径其实非常少的
我们只能从电视上 或者是报纸上 或者是广播里去听 那当时最好的广告
老的广告 其实就是TVC 电视广告 这里的T就是television 电视广告的意思
但是现在已经完全没有太多的人看电视了 是吧 我们更多看的是手机的
所以我们会发现 现在其实TVC广告它的含义已经更加的泛了
就是我们在手机里看到的所有的广告 我们也管它叫做TVC
其实我每天都会接触到大量的TVC 对不对
好 那这个就是我们说的TVC了Television commercial 电视商业广告的一个意思 是吧 现在我们在各个平台
手机端 网页端 平板 电视看到的所有的产品广告 基本上都叫做TVC啊 我随便说几个大家就很熟悉 比如说
水中贵族 百岁山 是吧 北纬40度 黄金大米
我这么一说大家是不是都特别有那个同感 是吧 今年过年不收礼啊 特别多
好 这些都叫做TVC
那为什么说TVC啊 在AI视频当中能够非常值钱呢 当然我这里说的百万不是所有TVC都能价值百万 但是我们会明显的感觉到
你用相同的时间去做一个TVC 它一定会比用相同的时间去做一个短剧或者是慢剧更加的值钱
好 那这里呢 我们就不得不提到TVC的一个商业属性了
TVC它是有非常强烈的商业价值的 也就是说
对于广告客户来说
他会通过 比如他花3万块钱买了你一篇TVC 对吧 但是他可以通过这3万块钱赚回更多的收益
这就是为什么TVC要比做短剧慢剧的城市更值钱的一个原因
也是更直接的一个原因
刚才我们看到的这个账号 我们可以来分析一下
本来想把这个板块放到后面了 但是既然已经打开了 咱们就来
详细的看一下
好 我们首先会看到这个账号 它其实做的非常的讨俏啊 当然
注意这个账号 它不是一个零粉旗号的 这个账号我是很了解的 它不是一个零粉旗号的 比如说老师他只发了
多少条呀 246
发了18条就100多万粉丝了 这可能吗 事实证明这可能性很小
大概率呢是买了一个账号
买了一个账号 但是我不建议你们去买账号啊 这个属于公司行为 这肯定是一个团队 对吧
比如说人家花了10万20万
去买了一个账号
其实10万20万买一个百万级的账号是非常便宜的了
OK 我们来看一下
那他是怎么去做的 怎么样去变现的呢 我们会发现他的所有的视频全部都是TVC 咱们随便打开一个看一眼啊
工人的地狱时刻
我叫1573
看起来人还在工位
但脑袋好像已经在神游
这太离谱
我已经困到大脑乱马了
小王
准备一下
10分钟后会议室 年终总结汇报
好的老板
把我们的看完
一会就要这样上去讲吗
我完蛋了
不行
得想个办法
能听到声音吗
应该还比较清晰
检测到高危打工人
是否执行丝滑重启
高危打工人
这个时候产品在真正的出来
前天其实一直都在过蝴蝶对吧
你发什么呆呢
赶紧去汇报吧
汇报而已
我已经满血复活了
各位下午好
下面由我开始汇报
你刚才
吃错药了
好我们来看完啊
还有最后一点了
好
聪明的同学已经看出来了
他其实做的并没有十分的精良
并没有非常非常极致的精良
但是我们已经感觉到他的目的已经达到了
是吧
好
那我们来分析一下这个账号是如何去变现的
大家可以把你们认为这个账号如何变现的这种
想法打在我们的公屏上
那我给大家来说一下
这个账号他是这样去变现的
我还
因为我认识他们内部的一个人
我来
介绍一下
那这个账号呢
他是这样去变现的
我们会发现他现在账号里发了18条左右的广告
对吧
那么其中有几条是真正的广告
大概有一半左右是真正的广告
还有一半左右呢
是
这个就是这个制作者制作公司他们做出来的一个demo
当然我们作为观看者我们大概率也看不出来哪个是哪个不是啊
看起来好像都是
是吧
OK
那么他首先会先自发性的做几个非真正广告的
这种虚拟广告出来
所以今天我会教大家如何去做一个虚拟广告啊
他先去做了几个
虚拟的广告出来
那做完之后他就可以拿着这个demo拿着这个最终的数据啊不管人家投留了还是没投留总之现在看起来是吧我们作为
不懂自媒体的同学你乍一看觉得哇这个数这个数据非常好
如果你是广告客户啊你哇这个数据特别好
那这个时候广告客户是不是就会找你
会非常信任你因为你的数据摆放在这里啊你第一条看
第一条就1.1万1.1万赞啊那广告客户看到之后认为这个数据非常的好
好那接下来他就会找你
那有可能你前面从从这个比如你自己起的号吧或者是你头抖家你可能花了有个五万块钱是吧
OK
当你找到广告客户之后以这样的粉丝体量加这样的视频数据那一般情况下你报价是可以报到几十万的啊就是你的广告费是可以报到几十万的
OK那这个时候也也也许你的前四条是纯虚拟的广告从第五条开始是一个真正广告OK那接下来会怎么办同学
报价60万一条广告啊举一个例子
然后你前面几条可能只投了一万的斗价
最后净赚多少
净赚55万
明白这个道理了吧
他就是这样去赚钱的啊做一些虚拟的然后付出一些斗价投入一些成本之后把数据做好看
然后呢
再通过接一条真正货真价实的广告回来然后把前面的成本再覆盖掉
对
有点欺骗客户那他没有在欺骗客户啊
来我跟你们说一下啊为什么我说他们并没有欺骗客户
因为客户要的是曝光量
而他通过斗加投出去的
刚刚好就是曝光量
大家能够明白吧
然后他也认认真真地做了一个
比较精致的TVC广告所以其实没有欺骗任何一方啊因为客户要的是曝光量
大家明白什么叫曝光量吗比如说你在
西湖边上的那个大屏上投了一个星期的广告花了26万
其期间有这个10万人看过那条广告他本质上也是曝光量
那么我在懂音上
买啊这个10万的播放本质上依然是曝光量大家明白吧其实对于广告客户来说没有任何的区别啊没有任何的区别
唯一的区别可能在哪里就是他
在抖音里头的广告是可以去选谁可以看这个广告的
这个其实要更好啊所以那个同学说欺骗消费者我觉得没有他甚至要
对于客户会更好一点
因为如果说你只是在
什么西湖边上大屏上做了一个广告其实看到这条广告的人
未必是你的目标消费者
而他如果在抖音做广告的话他可以刚刚好把客户想要的目标消费者
投到他们的面前把这个广告因为投抖架的时候是可以选择
这个地域可以选择人群可以选择
这个城市对吧都是可以进行选择的
所以甚至要比传统的在电视上投放广告效果会更好一点
嗯明白这个意思了吧
他就是这个意思啊就是这个逻辑
那就通过这种方式就可以去变现了大家其实
说老师我没有那么多启动资金动不动上啊就投1万块钱的斗家
OK那你投500是吧
总之这种方式已经被别人跑通了那你是可以去进行模仿的
Digital branding已经很重要了是的呀就是这样的
客户给了10万经费作品达不到客户要求的效果那自己花了12万投斗家那怎么可能呢
如果你的视频投了12万斗家都没有达到1万的点赞
那只能说明视频做的实在是太烂了啊不能那么做啊那那你是做的太烂了那不是那不是那个抖音的问题也不是客户的问题那是你自己的问题
那你做那么烂你还接那么贵广告都不活该吗
说我说话有点难听啊那事实就是这样
你去做项目你前提是你得能把项目做好你不能说
我就纯头抖家
抖家同学们注意啊他不是变魔法
如果抖家能变魔法的话这个事实上就轮不到我们有任何的机会了啊如果抖家能变魔法的话
那全世界排名前前五百的企业人家
很有钱的对吧人家直接课金还有普通人啥事事实证明抖家是相对公平的啊
我我做了这么久包括在线下讲的时候同学们也是这么说的抖音和高考啊我认为是在普通人的生活当中
为二相对比较公平的两次机会啊两个地方
所以啊抖音你投抖家能有数据好的前提是你确实是
做的好才会有人点赞因为抖家的本质是给你增加曝光如果你做的很乱的话哪怕他投给一亿个人去看照样没人给你点赞明白吧同学们他本质上是你得做的好啊OK
那个罗毅同学你是真喜欢你真喜欢说英语呀
我给你开个直播你来讲英语好不好
不过我现在有很有这个说你的习惯
对也是一种赚钱的思路
本质上你这得做的好的大家明白吧
不是说
你随随便便做一个烂片然后你发的抖音上你投一个亿你就赚钱了没有这事啊就这个世界还是
虽然有很多的不公平但是总的来说还是比较公平的啊大家能明白吧总的来说抖音还是比较公平的
好那么现在大家肯定都理解TV了解TVC也知道TVC广告在抖音
这个平台上怎么赚钱的
包括很多大家看到的这种账号
其实现在谁是电视台同学们
那下抖音就是电视台啊
如果说你也有那样的一个账号那样的一个平台
有很多那样的
这个视频的demo出来那你其实就是一个电视台
你就是一个分发平台给别人去看到你做的很优质的视频
好
那么
接下来呢我们来说一下传统TVC的一个制作的流程
那一般情况下在传统制作的时候是非常的麻烦的啊
虽然现在我们用AI做依然跟这个流程差不多但是里面真正去做的工作
具体事无巨细的工作
它已经非常非常的省事了对吧
那过去你需要先去接下客户
过去客户可没有主动找上门来的啊你得自己去跟人家去谈
但是现在如果你抖音做的非常好的话像我所有的广告客户全都是自己送上门来的啊就一天我差不多能加10到20个左右的广告客户
里面有一些是这个
当然我加的更多的是AI工具啊比如说像
LibTV
像这个
小云雀
对吧
豆包
最近其实都有做
假如看我视频的话最近我刚做了一条
豆包的一条广告还有一条LibTV的广告还有一条
哥哥AI音乐的广告
这三条是广告其他的是
纯教程
但大家可能看不出来是吧这就是我这个账号比较
比较好的一点啊我自己感觉
好那我们可以来看一下传统咱们去做的话你需要先去谈客户就不能像现在一样主动等客户送上门来啦像星图里面是吧
然后是品牌策略的一个分析
你要去帮客户进行一个品牌的拆解啊这里给大家看一下我这里呢做了一张这样的小图
哎这小图呢待会我们在制作的过程当中会用的到这是一个虚拟的项目哎怎么让我关了再给打开啊
大部分同学你肯定没有什么产品对吧
那么我会带着大家先去虚拟一个产品
把这个产品的品牌定位啊产品系列产品定位产品参数啊我们都去给他虚拟的策划出来
这个时候你才能有一定的思路对吧因为现在我没有真正的客户真正的甲方啊所以我们需要去自己拟定一个虚拟的产品把这个思路给他梳理出来
好
每条广告多少钱
你猜啊你注册一个馋妈妈你就能看到所有博主的广告报价
你可以去看一看
啊我给你们说一下AIGC的头部博主一条广告是50万
自己算吧我算是我算是腰部靠上一点点啊我算是腰部靠上一点点
这差不多是他的
三分之一到一半左右
OK
来我们继续看下一个就是广告创意的一个策划
好过去这些部分每一个环节可能都需要一个人到多个人啊然后做分镜
做导演方案是吧甚至如果你里面设计到一些模特的话你还需要去选角
去去不断的去让这个演员过来试镜
如果是多个演员还得多个演员过来试镜啊所以过去的这个
这个过程非常的复杂包括拍摄的时候是很贵的
最近有很多同学问我啊这个TVC广告包括去做短剧的时候怎么去报价
我呢给到大家一个公式想不想知道怎么去报价的公式同学们想知道的抠个想
来不想知道我就继续往后讲了想知道怎么报价的抠个想
老摔到我
明星代言也很贵呀搞虚拟明星虚拟明星是永远不会去翻车的好
大家想知道怎么去报价我现在大概给大家写一个公式啊
我给你们写的这个公式不是报价公式是一个计算成本的公式
你在这个公式的基础上
再去干嘛呢我写到咱们今天的笔记里吧
我这个笔记就先这样了时间有限了不能做的太好看了
但是但是绝对干啊绝对干我们在这里写一下
AI影视报价公式
这里跟大家说一下这个单子现在是鱼龙混杂的那种我在直播间里面什么
就那种割韭菜大家可千万别信上来跟你说啊
报了我这个199然后呢就给你
派单啊怎么怎么地的给你
包派一年
然后你进去之后发现自己跟那个奴隶一样啊就5050块钱一分钟最后你算力花了150
就那种的千万不要信啊
基本上你接的单子一分钟如果低于350了
那铁定就是
18100手单了啊就别的就别考虑接了如果
350以上还勉强能接其实350已经是肯定是三手单以上了就不用想啊
肯定是三手单以上的
一手单哪怕是现在最简陋的城市也不可能这么便宜的啊一手单最便宜最便宜
他也得在600到800左右就是最便宜的不能再便宜的粗质滥造的剧他也不可能那么便宜的啊就是大家如果说
遇到那种骗人的就先不要信最后你这个血本无归是吧算力出去还不给你结款啊
OK我们来说一下这个报价公式
好怎么去算呢
这样去算啊
就是你的时薪
怎么算你的时薪啊
这个我说一下就是
月薪
我在下面上面去写啊
好
如何计算时薪
月薪
月薪不知道多少你就现在投个boss啊你看看你标到多少的时候会有人主动来跟你聊那就是你的月薪
月薪如果工作过的人可能很容易估算自己的月薪对吧
你的月薪
除以
22天
除以22天
除以
除呢
除号在哪
除以
除以22一个月工作22天
再
除以多少呢
8小时
好就是你的时薪
这时候你就算出来了对吧
然后呢你如何去计算自己的成本呢
时薪
乘以
你的制作时长
加修改时长
好这个是你的固定的一个公时的钱对吧
然后呢制作时长加修改时长加算力成本
这个算力也要把你修改的时候的算力加上啊
算力成本
等于
啊你的制作成本
好
那我的建议就是在这个的基础上
你能报多高就报多高啊这个就要看你谈判的能力了
也就是说你只要能达到比这个高你就铁定不赔本啊你如果比这个低了我建议呢就不要去接了
同学说老师我初学啊千万不要抱有这种形态
你要么就学的特别好做特别好去接高价一点的单子要么就
不要接啊最后你没准自己再搭几千块钱进去是吧那就得不偿失了啊
OK那这个就是一个报价公式
在这个基础上啊能报多高就报多高啊那么同学说老师那我是不是可以报无限高我我报1000万一个那肯定是不行的你去和什么去衡量呢你去和他传统的拍摄去衡量
对吧为什么我讲到这里之后要跟大家说一个这个就是因为和传统的啊这个流程去衡量的时候你会发现
过去啊客户他如果去找一个制作公司一个再简单不过的TVC也至少要花到15万以上
所以你的报价现在报到三万五万一点都不为过客户一点都不会觉得贵因为他是和传统巨组去进行衡量的
但是咱们作为制作者我们肯定要讲良心不能给人家做一个粗质滥造的东西肯定要做一个比较好的东西对吧
OK那这个就是我给到大家的一个建议啊基本上现在一分钟左右的大家报到
八千到三万之间都是比较合理的区间啊就如果你以个人的这个
个人的这样的一个
或者是小小团队是吧一到三人的一个小团队去进行交付的话你最低最低是绝对不可以低于三千的啊就是我刚建议是八千
到三万那如果你实在是老时候实在接不到活我现在就没有
活啊我我就是想那个练手有人愿意三千五给我做那也可以做啊但是我建议是那么高如果便宜到几百
就就把它拉黑并且冲它放一个屁就可以了是吧开玩笑啊
粉丝量的百分之六十不是的啊我说的这个TVC也包含了城市不一定你是博主你才可以接就比如说你只是单纯的会做你的朋友给你介绍来一些单子那你就可以这样去报价
一起长大 今天怎么那么多我喜欢说英语的同学啊
我也得一边看那个互动去一边一边脑子里想着啊这这句什么意思那句什么意思
好OK然后呢后面还会有复杂的后期制作啊成片交付所以我们用传统的方式做是非常贵的啊大家应该都明白了吧
那现在啊AI时代已经来了我们需要经历一个这样的流程
首先啊这个流程
虽然简化了但是很多流程它是必不可少的
比如说做产品分析的这一步
那这一步我认为是非常关键的即便现在AI可以直接帮你分析但是我建议同学们还是要过脑子的
因为所有的现在非常厉害的品牌你能记得住叫出名字的品牌它都一定是经过深思熟虑
并且啊这个制作者也好还有他的
这个负责人也好他们对产品的调形定位锚点是非常了解的
待会我会带着大家用AI去走一遍这个过程啊这个过程是不可省略的也不能完全不动脑子
因为你完全不动脑子老板有可能也会听我今天的课他学会了他不会找你了明白吧所以呢就是大家一定要去
动脑子过脑子的把它生成的内容进行一个详细的分析
最近我其实也一直
在研究TVC嘛
所以我发现一个问题就是目前AI他分析能力真的是比较强的啊就是可能能够超越很多非科班的人科班的他可能目前
能达到一个差不多或者有时候有一点傻的水平
但是和非科班同学相比他一定比你强啊所以要多去学习AI生成出来的这个内容
好然后呢就是广告的定位创意策划啊这三点是非常重要的
OK从第四个步骤开始呢我们就进入进入了视觉设定的一个过程当中我们可能要去出
这个美术设定对吧然后呢资产的一个设置人物长什么样子
我们的广告里面啊这个人物的形象是什么样子的对吧然后
分镜怎么样去做视频如何去生成
最后呢会进行一个生意和剪辑的包装那最近我发现啊过去很麻烦的一步就是去加背景音乐的这一步现在已经可以用LibTV的这个
自动的agent去给他加了所以除了贵
没啥毛病啊
就是贵这点就有点难受
今天的课是没有任何广告的大家不用担心啊我说到LibTV就是单纯的觉得挺好用的
没有其他的原因啊
我感觉LibTV应该欠了我一个亿的广告费啊
我每节课我都在用它但是我确实今天真的是没有收广告费的大家不用担心啊
OK然后最后会生成一个成片
很多同学问我说老师
现在AI能不能去做剪辑了是吧
OK那我来跟大家说像咱们有节课讲的XCAT那个叫做Web Cutting就是AI剪辑
那它的其实更加适合于去剪一些像
直播切片呢就是比如你直播了三个多小时然后你想从里面提取一些高光
这个是可以用那个软件去做的
但是如果你想做类似于我这种口播的内容
或者比较精致的剧情片
目前来说的话还是需要自己手挫的
那如果不是特别精致的剧情片或者是比较短的剧情
可以考虑使用Lib TV来做
因为如果说很长你做了40分钟一个小时或者是十几分钟
你用Lib TV再给你配音乐的话那就太贵了
同学们啊太可怕了那得多少钱呢
所以
大概率啊现在我们去做后期的包装去做剪辑
还是得通过自己的手挫来进行完成的
发的时候带翻译没关系我能看懂的
哈喽你好郑云来啦
郑云是咱们的这个系统课的同学
刚充了type now
type now也是可以的
那个type now我觉得和LibTV没啥区别
大家不一定非要跟我用一样
方法都是相通的
你像现在那个Flova
RHTV
LibTV
Type now
全都是可以用Agent进行对话
就是咱们今天学到的东西大家如果是冲了的话可不要再冲第二个
太贵了
没有必要
你们只要冲了一个就可以了
包括
吉梦其实都是可以的
吉梦只是生涂生的现在不如那个LibTV好吗
没有GPT的模型他只能用字节系的
但是其他的他还是很好的
郑云竟然来了
Mil是谁
就大家换了网名之后都分不清谁是谁
每次开课我感觉都有好多线下班同学过来学
线下班同学确实需要学每周都得过来
因为会讲一些新的东西
好OK
那咱们接下来呢
就准备开始干嘛啦
我们就准备开始实操了
实操之前我们先说一个三个小的技巧
这个三个技巧的话呢
大家在某一些要求比较高的TVC广告当中可能会用得到
第一个呢叫做气质锚定啊
就是你需要去确定一下这个产品的气质
啥意思
啥叫气质呢
哎现在呢咱们就举个例子
那么人都有气质是吧
时而
这个看起来很精干
这个精干这词是不是太远化呀
老家的话不知道大家能不能听懂什么叫精干
精神干练的意思啊
我原来一直以为这是一个词
然后后来发现这是一个太远的方言
就是很精神干练啊
有的人那有的人呢
就很猥琐
是吧
那有的人呢就很看起来
很搞笑啊
比如说我现在一说
小月月
一说这个沈童
你就觉得
光看到他那张脸
我就特别想笑了
是吧
那每一个人他都是有气质的
那看到大帆老师是什么感觉呢
你们可以告诉我啊
底下说
傻叉
好
之前老人说我在讲公开课的时候
笑声特别的魔性搞到现在都有点不敢笑了怕别人嘲笑我
好
OK那我们说
人有气质产品也一定是有气质的啊咱们现在随便打开几个产品是吧
比如说我们
随便上个淘宝也好啊上个
我们随便打开淘宝打开京东吧咱们打开京东我们随便找几个产品咱们来看看他的气质
因为我刚好这几天做了一个Lovart的一个电商设计的案例这是我做那条视频里的
所有的案例啊
大家过几天就会看到了有没有想学电商设计这让我说到这儿想学电商设计的扣个1我给大家系统的把那个电商设计的全流程可以给你们在
在我们的社群课里面讲一讲
有没有想是电商设计的就是给网店做装修的比如主图怎么做详情页怎么做
想学
魔戒
魔哈哈
想学想学上下节课讲啊
下节课或者是下下节课
看情况反正肯定会讲的不是下节课就是下下节课行咱话说回来
所谓的品牌情绪版
你可以省也可以不省
咱们现在随便打开一个产品咱们来感受一下它的情绪就把它比作一个活人
咱们来感受一下这个情绪啊怎么进来时候都是这个手串呢
随便咱打开你看
同样都是被子啊它的这个感觉气质都是不一样的咱们随便打开一个咱们看一看
呃手势咱们就说一下手势啊好我们来看这个手串
咱们来看这个手串哎呀还让我登录一下这就有点讨厌了那我就不登了啊省得让你们看我在买了是吧
好我先给大家
咱们先来看啊第1个我们先看这个产品
好第1个产品大家觉得看到这个产品之后想到一个什么样的形象
把它比作一个人啊给它拟人一下
谁会戴这个镯子
我第一反应啊看到这个
看到这个老凤翔的logo又看到这里的古法心经的这种字体再看到这个镯子
土豪
可以说再详细一点
其实我家里面的乡村贵妇
我家里其实最喜欢买金手式的是我的奶奶
是我奶奶因为
对于这个传统一些的人他总觉得
好像在家里面存一些这种
打我家没存啊
不要瞎想
就在家里面啊对于老人来说在家里面放一些这种
首饰啊他可能会觉得就是很有安全感
有一种这种包括他如果买了之后就送给别人他会有一种
一种心意在里面啊所以我们会发现
一个产品他是有气质的从这个产品本身的一个设计在里面莲花对吧里面是心晶
经啊是印的是佛经
然后呢
加上这个古法的一个就古风的一个字体在家里面这种
大家看上面的一些小装饰小贴片全部都是这种黄金的渐变他很有可能大概率是卖给中老年的
有钱的中老年人群的对吧
而且可能以女性为助啊以拙子男性其实挨戴拙子的并不是特别的多啊
OK那我们再来看一下这个同样的都是一个手串是吧那个是一个金拙的这是一个手串
好这个小叶子坛谁喜欢带同学们
你们家里绝对啊至少有一个
爷爷或者是叔叔或者爸爸
喜欢买小叶子坛手串的
我没有猜错吧
对吧哎这种你看就是一个中老年的男性
特别喜欢这个风格
那同学说老师谁说的我二多岁我喜欢小叶子坛
虽然你喜欢小叶子坛但是你会买那种相对比较时尚的款式
而不会买这种上面带一个中国节下面带俩葫芦的
我没猜错吧对吧你可能会买这个啊这个可能年纪大点的觉得太简陋了但是年轻人会觉得
简阅大起又古风感啊又国潮感哎他会针对不同的人去做
好现在大家应该都明白了我们拿这个手串举个例子
这个就是一个
50多岁的一个老爷爷可能每天盘着串去门口下象棋是吧
那么上面这个呢就是一个
老奶奶是一个70多岁的60多岁的一个老奶奶
那她呢就特别喜欢戴金镯子
然后有时间了去跟自己的小伙伴跳跳广场舞或者是这个知之毛衣
你就是不是有那个画面感了
这就是气质啊同学们
这就是调性加气质
那我们来看一下我们回到刚才的这个产品当中
好我们来看一下这个产品
中年的你都好几串了
一不小心
讲课一不小心就会伤人了
好
我们回来
年轻的老板外国人可喜欢了是吗
那外国人他其实分辨不出来国潮和和这个
不国潮他就觉得都是中国风看起来都挺神奇的就跟咱们现在
咱们去出国买一些我们没见过的东西一样都都很新鲜
好
所以第一件事呢就是去锚定TVC的气质
然后去锚定他的气质
那这里呢其实我在
这个提示词我就不宣传给大家演示咱们主要演示后面的东西啊为什么不演示了呢因为咱们我在我的视频里面
其实有非常详细的
把这个流程做出来啊
大家可以来看一下这个是我那条视频的一个资料分享可以给大家去看一下我们去
锚定啊这个
视频的风格用的是什么样的一个提
提示词在这大家看到了吧
哎是这样的一个公式刚才其实我已经带着大家去想过一遍了产品的属性
比如说老年手镯
核心的情绪是什么样子的啊老年喜庆是吧吉祥啊
这个就是核心的情绪
然后呢高级的场景老年人最渴望的这里说的高级不是那种金光灿灿的那种华丽的高级咱们这里说的是对于目标消费者来说什么样的场景是他向往的
好什么样的场景是中老年人向往的同学们他们其实很期待有钱吗不一定是吧
他们很期待买很多东西嘛也不一定但是中老年人最期待的一定是
合家团圆啊就如果说你做一个那种新年的场景所有的
一家人非常温馨的在一起然后一个老奶奶拿出了老凤翔手镯送给了他的小孙女
这个就是老人非常渴望看到的场景啊所以如果你这样做的话可能把这个目标消费者他就会很喜欢
家和万事实行然后理想的人物哎大家想想这个对于老年人来说他觉得什么样的老年人非常的值得老年人的向往呢
同学们想一想
上次我讲线下班啊同学说老师就是老了还有还有这个老奶奶喜欢的老爷爷
其实这不是大部分老年人向往大部分老年人向往的是什么呢是健康和团圆啊这是大部分老年人向往的事情就是
寿命很长身体健康并且呢自己的孩子们都能
围着自己是吧这就是对于老年人最幸福的事情啊
然后光影的色调那肯定很吉祥的金色或者是橙色这种很温暖的暖色调
镜头语言啊比如说这个老人抱着孙子啊老人开开心心的这种啊满头银发但是非常的
呃这个
微胖是吧非常的开心的
呃这个合家团聚的一个全景的画面啊
OK这个就是广告气质的一个设计的公式大家可以按照刚才我带着你们去构思的整个流程去想一下这里给到大家三个案例四个案例啊我这里就不念了大家可以到时候下课之后看一下这个公式
好这是第1个啊这是第2个
这是第1个OK那接下来呢再来说一些其他的啊大家可能会用得到的一些技巧
那第2个就是视觉符号的表达方法
好什么叫做视觉符号呢我这里来说一下很多同学去生成视频的时候特别喜欢加一些这种抽象词
这也是我去接到项目的时候最反感
甲方说的话啊做过设计的或者是做过影片的你们肯定都特别讨厌听到这几个词高端
大气上档刺是不是瞬间想给它拉黑并且冲它放一个屁对吧太讨厌了啊因为什么呢因为客户的高端大气上档刺和你的高端大气上档刺它可完全不是一个画风啊我给大家举个例子客户你的高端大气上档刺一般长啥样呢给你们举个例子啊咱们就以这个
这个比如说装修美丽对吧比如说这个插季风
好这个是很多设计师以为的高端大气上档刺比如说长这样啊这个可能都没有那么高端大气上档刺啊咱们
我看哪个比较高端一点或者是工业风是吧我给你们
这个看起来还比较的高端这一看里面的任何一个家具都很贵
有没有感觉到但是客户的高端可不一定是这个样子了啊
我给你们送一下巴勒洛克装修
哎高客户心里的高端
长这样啊长这样咱也不评论谁谁阳气谁土啊总之就是学过专业的人他大概率在这个时代里他不会喜欢这么繁复的东西的
ok好所以说啊AI他有时候就跟你的客户一样你不能去给他一些虚词一些
抽象词啊然后让客户去猜是吧你这样也对客户是一种不负责任的一种行为你不能说我要高端的打气的上打字的
所以这个时候你给他提出的视觉符号就是要可视化的咱们现在随便举一个例子
来我来给你们说一下什么叫啊就是把这个意向对吧把意向转化成可视化的东西
好视觉符号那么大家想到的很多词他可能都很抽象比如说自由这叫抽象词
治愈抽象词高级轻盈持久安全这些全部都是抽象词
所以你给到AI这些东西他大概率会给你一些非常刻板的印象对呀没错啊AI他的大脑也是有刻板思维的
所以这个时候你要把这些抽象词转换成具象真正可实施的画面
比如说自由咱们就给他转换成海鸟啊海浪啊飞鸟啊一个正在太阳底下对吧
狂奔的人那些话怎么说的呢
我可以回想到啊西洋西夏那个狂奔的下午那是我逝去的那是我即将逝去的青春
是吧给他一种这样的感觉啊把我们的这种
卖点转换成抽象的转换成具象的东西
好比如说在奔跑的人啊像这样的一个效果
好这是视频的原素材啊
大家做的时候可以把这生意的剪辑掉
好这样去体现自由是不是就特别好了
对吧好我们再来一个这样去体现自由
你不要真正把自由两个字打在你的那个屏幕上看起来就特别蠢啊对不对
比如说我想告诉别人我是一个好男孩啊我是一个好女人
那你不能每天跟你的对象啊比如说你是个男生你不能每天跟你的女朋友说我可好了
我是个好人啊然后对方只会觉得
你脑子有炮是吧
那如果说你们俩在过马路的时候你非常有意识的让他站在安全的那一侧
哎这个就是什么呢就是用具体的行为换句话说在影视里面就是用具体的镜头来表现这种感觉
大家能够明白这个意思了吧
嗯面向大海
春暖花开
咱的审美没问题
爸妈装修就喜欢那种风格对吧
闻脑门上好男人
就现在有的时候不喜欢某些明星的原因就是因为这个就是有些明星的特别有
确实长得很帅但是他好像他那个行为啊包括
去游之前的黄晓明其实就给人这种感觉但是黄晓明现在不这样黄晓明自从离婚之后就不游了是吧
就是去游之前的黄晓明就总得有一种给人一种感觉就是我好帅啊他把那个我好帅印在脸上
其实帅他不是通过那种
油腻的表情啊或者油腻的动作体现出来的他体现在人的方方面面比如这个人很有素质
对吧等等等等很清爽每次都干干净净的一看就是经常洗澡
他体现在这些小的细节上
那我们做影视也是一样的啊他体现在一些小的细节上我们把这些抽象子给他转化成具象的画面
好那么这个时候大家一定会有一个问题问
老师
我不知道该怎么去转化
是吧好那如果你有这个问题的话你可以打开豆包
我现在有点不敢打开
GPT了我怕他会卡
所以现在呢咱们就暂时用豆包减漏的替代一下好吧待会如果说不卡我就再打开GPT
因为我现在不敢开GPT了
咱们先用豆包你可以这样去给他一个要求
比如说
现在你是
一位
TVC
这个
编导
我希望
你能够帮我
将
客户的
抽象需求
这个我现场手挫的同学们就是大家也要学会这个手挫提示词的这个方法我待会给你们大概说一下这个结构啊
我希望你能够将
帮我将客户的抽象概念
和需求
具象
化
为
可视化的
这个镜头描述
描述
好这里可以跟他说一下
无需生成分镜
紧
生成一句
话
的
具象
描述即可
即可
客户
提出的
或者客户给的
抽象词
是
高端
是吧然后呢
产品
是
移动硬盘
或者是咱们这个别给他倒难题了
产品是
白酒
好
可视化的镜头描述
请你给我出
5个
可视化的镜头描述方案
好啊比如咱们就下去写那这段提出词什么样的一个结构呢
好其实外面不提起动提出词总共就这么一种结构
好你就是
生土也好生视频好问问题好永远这个结构他绝对是通用的
第一个就是给到他一个角色啊这是他给到他一个身份的角色
然后就是什么呢一个基础的描述
我希望你
干件什么事对吧比如今天我招聘了一个编导然后这个编导要干什么事情先跟他说清楚
接下来就是一个详细的描述
你只要按照这个逻辑去提问的话你这辈子都不需要多问几次提示词啊就你永远
只要问一句话就够了
开的时间长了不开都看不了我的直播和傻
黄晓明律师寒在录上那没事他那那他肯定不会先给我发律师寒的全网说他游的人太多了
这些谢谢你们可以问AI吗当然可以了AI就是最好的老师了我喝口水有点想咳嗽
OK来我们生成一下看看这段提示词可不可行不可行
咱们就去修改他
我写这一次有时候少量的时候也是会翻车的正常啊
你们写你们也会翻车吗
好来
不错啊非常棒
我把这段也待会给你们沾到笔记里面
暗掉极简品酒屋的里面
溜金纹路白酒瓶静置在整块天然黑色大理石的台面上
一束侧光勾勒瓶身通透轮廓
是不是还那种高端感出来了
所以我们需要把自己的这些概念
给到AI然后就可以生成出来很多的这种
很高级的这样的一些画面了
好这个就是给到大家一些就是营造一些高级感或者我们不用那么直白的去体现一些广告的一些小技巧
好那么产品呢往往会在
最后去登场
当然这里说的最后登场不一定是配
适配于所有的广告哈这里给大家看两种
量级的广告一个呢是比较偏短的
都是AI做的一个比较偏短的它呢就比较适合于产品
早一点出来啊然后全程体现它的表情因为广告如果很短的情况下
你不能只让它出现一秒钟就有点尴尬了是吧
所以我们让它全程都在啊多去展示产品
那么还有一种呢时间在30秒到几分钟左右以上了那这个时候呢我们就可以把这个产品放到最后去亮相
现在我们看其中的一种啊这个是一个运动鞋的也是我后面会去
展示的一个案例
大概明天会给大家发这条视频啊大家到时候可以去看一下
好这是一条
好这是一个极简形式的这样一个TVC那接下来我们再来看一个
相当相对来说时间拉长了一些那我们的产品呢就可以
在做了一些铺垫之后
最后登场你会发现我的这条TVC广告它的品质要比我们刚才在那个账号里看的都要好啊
好我们来看一下这条广告
这个是我的视频案例的一个成片啊我们可以来看一看
下面
好我们一起来
看一下
一开始我们先去出空镜对吧先来体现这种
情景啊然后是
一种
调性在里面出现了模特
这时候你依然不知道我的场景是什么对吧
我们先
把一种
你向往的生活或者向往的这种场景先提醒出来这个时候到了后面才逐渐出现
然后用其他的这些场景
做一个调性和氛围的烘托
最后再次出现一个美女
蝴蝶化成一抹香
Scent arrives before memory does
And lets this moment linger forever
一看就觉得蛮贵的
是吧
觉得这个产品确实很贵
下了1000块钱都买不到这瓶香水的感觉
是不是
好
那么这个就是我刚才说的时间站线拉的比较长的时候
我们就可以在前面多铺垫一些
刚才跟大家说的
抽象词掌握成巨像的画面
可以是有产品的
也可以是完全的空镜
然后呢我们在最终给它形成一个
这样的产品TVC广告片
一共是49秒差不多50秒的一个时间
差不多就是这样的一个逻辑
好
那现在大家理论或者是一些注意的事项
我们已经了解的差不多了
那接下来呢我们就开始实操先从skill的训练方法开始
先从用skill去生成的方法开始
我们先来做
然后呢
我们待会我再给大家说一下
如果你里面没有你需要的skill
我们怎么样自己去错一套skill出来
这待会咱们来详细的去讲
OK到目前为止还能跟上的同学我们扣一个1好吗
大家这个你们也记得喝水的
这一节课时间也挺长的
好的
能跟上我就很开心
那接下来呢
咱们就进入到了
下一个板块了
我们接下来就进入到TVC广告短片的一个操作带链了
这里呢咱们也没有时间用到所有的
用完所有的这个工具
其实我这个成片有一部分的镜头是用可灵声的 有一部分镜头是用Cdance 2.0声的
就有一些比较短的特写可灵的那个质感会更好一点 大家如果说
你们Cdance 2.0声成了15秒觉得
挺满意的 但是单独的有那么一两个特写镜头不太喜欢的时候
那大家就可以用可灵的3.0去升一下这个单镜头 效果还是比较不错的
我们有时候偶尔也会拿可灵或者是进到急梦里面去补足一下
好 那接下来呢咱们就用LibTV来做了 我这里呢
大家如果说冲了其他的这个账号的话 你是可以
自己去用你的其他的工具的 比如说
像loveart或者是吉梦或者是RHTV等等等等的 你其实都可以去使用它
好 那么我来说一下 有没有这个
没用过LibTV的同学 一次都没用过的同学大家抠个0 好吗 我就大概用一分钟的时间还是把基础的操作说一下
怕你们不知道怎么回事
对可灵他就是去生成单镜头的质感还是非常不错的
有没有不会用LibTV的 有 哎呀 还不少呢 我大概说一嘴啊 就是
还是那句话 大家友好讨论 如果说老师我都会了 我在这听了一个多月了 两个月了 我已经讲了好多遍LibTV了
你别讲了啊 我还是要照顾一下新来的同学 好吧 大家互相谅解啊 因为有同学是刚刚来的
好 那我来说一下LibTV 它是一个画布形式的
这样的一个节点画布形式的这样的一个工具
那么你进来之后呢 它有一个主页 是吧 进来之后它是这个样子的
好 它其实你可以在这个区域直接去
写提示词 但是我不建议大家在这里去写
它就开始给你自动建工程 就比较的麻烦
尤其是很多同学说 老师我觉得它这个有点贵 这个会员有点贵啊 我想跟其他的人一起去共用
好 那如果你直接在这新建
在这里直接输入的话就比较的麻烦 容易跟别人串了 是吧
那如果说你跟别人共用的话 或者你想
完整的整齐的整理你的项目的话
我比较建议大家呢 点击这里的开始创作
新建一个自己的项目 然后在里面去
做图
好
或者是生视频 我们点一下这个新建项目 哎 怎么这么慢呢 今天 再来一遍啊
好 点击开始创作
OK 这样呢 你就新建了一个画布
新手到这里呢 都会比较的懵 老师这是怎么回事 我来给大家介绍一下
这个画布其实它现在主要的操作区就是两个
板块 上面其实有一个工作流 故事版 咱们比较常用的就是这个
工作流 是吧
好 然后呢 它右边有一个比较 现在我认为近期我很常用的一个功能 也是它新出的 出了不到半个月
叫Agent功能
这个功能之前像RGTV也好 Flava也好 他们早就有这个功能了
但是
我个人感觉
这个功能目前来说就是LibTV最好用
不是广告啊 就是我自己的感觉
因为它这个功能
没有什么废的
就是我所谓的废的就是不会说你跟他对了半天话给你建了一堆
小垃圾啊 然后废了你几千个点数
目前来说
LibTV的这边这一侧的这个对话它我认为啊 在我的制作过程来说
我感觉成本并没有变高 并没有明显变高 可能
因为我我刚开始用时间不长 高肯定是高的那么一点点 因为它肯定会造成一点点的浪费
但是
没有高太多 甚至是高的不明显
那我觉得还是比较好用的
我们现在说一下左边这个啊 这个是一个
画布
在这个画布里你可以双击去新建各种各样的节点 比如说新建一个文本 就可以在这个里面点自己编写内容 可以在里面去写剧本
然后有了剧本之后 拉一个
链条出来
然后呢松开你的鼠标 再点图片 你就可以根据左侧的剧本去生成右侧的分镜
生成完右侧的分镜之后 可以再拉一个节点 然后根据你的分镜图再去生成一个视频
你也可以直接双击去新建一个图片节点 这样就相当于你去用midjourney或者是寂寞或者是豆包 在里面生图是一样的
在豆包里生图你就直接说给我生成了什么图 但是在这里生图你就要双击一下
新建一个图片节点 再去告诉他帮你生成什么图像
他是这样的 包括你也可以双击去新建一个视频的节点
以及音频的节点 再双击一个你可以新建音频的节点 都是非常方便的
好 OK 这是新建的方式 当然了我们还有其他的方式 比如说把你自己的图可以给他拖拽进来 对吧 比如说
你自己设计了一个很漂亮的运动鞋 那你就可以把它
直接拖拽进来 然后你可以用你拖拽进来的这张图再点这个加号
然后新建用这张图去生成一个视频 也是可以的
他就是非常的自如的操作 大家现在没用过 你可能听觉得有点懵 其实你一上手就会发现还是非常非常
非常简单的 没有文生图 当然有了
图片 你在下面直接文生图啊 比如说
生成一只小猫咪 对吧 一只
小猫咪 这就是文生图 直接点就行了
好 然后咱们新建节点这个讲完了 讲完了之后我们来说一下什么呢 每个节点下面都有它相关的一些设置的选项
比如说你可以在下面去切换生成的模型
大家尽量啊 闭眼去选择它就可以了 看到了吧 就是Lib的Image
这个就是ChatGPT的Image2模型
它就是这个 非常非常的方便 然后这个是Net-of-Net的模型
然后这个是Gimon的模型 Gimon的模型现在排到前面来的是因为它的生成效果升级了 比原来好用了一些
悠传是Midjourney的模型
但是一般情况下不出意外 你就用第一个模型 效果肯定是最好的
好 然后呢 旁边的这个是它的比例
清晰度 一般我们肯定要选择标准画质以上 也没必要 非要高品质 就贵了 是吧
标准画质2k 如果文字多 选2k 文字少 选1k 也是足够用的
然后生成数量就选一张 直接点击生成就可以了 那么
这个视频节点呢 也是一样的 我比如说双击个视频节点
对吧 然后呢 你可以在这里面去选模型 碧眼选择第1个 第2个 第3个看似便宜 其实你要多抽很多遍的卡
最后花的钱比第1个还多 是吧
除非正义要求不高的情况下 就选后面的两个
好 然后这里可以去选文生视频全能参考 一般你肯定会链接一些参考图的 它会自动变成全能参考
然后呢 这里是你生成的比例 如果是横版视频选择16比9 如果是数本视频选择9比16
然后清晰度 720是足够你去发布自媒体的平台了
480肯定是不行的 太模糊了 太小了 720是可以足够你发布自媒体平台的 1080p就非常的高清了
4k 那你不做那个龙标电影上映的电影没必要 是吧 太贵了 太可怕了
好 然后视频的时长最长可以拉到15秒
C dance 2.5上了之后就是30秒了 大家敬请期待吧
现在如果有人跟你说他已经开始用C dance 2.5 他就是个纯骗子啊 同学们 没上的啊 绝对没上的
好 OK
然后呢 音频咱们正常情况下开启 剩下一个啊 别被他骗了
好 那这里我要说一个非常重要的点啊 同学们 话重点了
这里我要说一个非常非常重要的点 就是大家看啊 这有一个清晰度
对吧 包括生徒的时候也有一个清晰度 那么当你去在旁边的agent和他对话的时候 你生视频的时候注意 一定必须把你的清晰度给他说出来
否则他就会按照非常清晰的那种给你生成 因为他想多赚钱 大家明白了吧 就比方说大家在这生的时候 你务必在右侧跟他对话的时候告诉他说
720p 你不说他就自动1080p了啊 这是一个重点 还有就是生徒的时候也是一样的 如果你不说他就自动给你2k 4k往上了啊 有可能你只要1k
你要告诉他的啊 必须要告诉他吧 否则他就以那个比较贵的方式去给你生成就非常的损 还有一个呢 就是他在右边咱们去用的时候
有的时候我们生成一个10秒钟的视频 明明一个节点就可能生成完 他就偏给你生三个或者两个节点 所以你务必要在右边跟他对话的时候跟他说只能生成一个节点
要不然他就很坑 很坑 很气人啊 OK 好
720后面有力部的模型变高清可以吗 不可以 效果不好 就是你可以生720之后再让他变1080的是OK的 但你其实直接生1080就行了 但是你如果妄想着480变成1080
想都不要想 效果特别的辣 绝对不行 我有个问题 我正在1080的视频上选择了2k补针 出来的视频不会动 只有音乐 你导出的时候是不是 那就是他的bug了 这个我解决不了
积分就哗哗哗的掉了 就是这个样子的 守住自己的这个钱包
好 那左边工作流基本上就是这个样子的 右边是干啥的呢 大家可以理解为左边是一个干活的地方 右边是给你干活的人 懂了吧
就是本来这公司里只有你一个人 你呢 需要在左边这个话不理哭哈哈的一个一个节点 一个节点去搭啊 当然现在依然
精品巨还得这么去做
但是现在批量生产的 或者要求没那么高的 或者比较短的啊 这个内容 咱们是完全可以用右边的方式做了
这个时候呢 之前是你一个人开了一个艺人公司 是吧 你好苦啊 每天什么都得干啊 你又得你又得做产品 又得当销售 又得当剪辑 是吧 你太你太苦了
然后你挣了点积蓄之后 你突然想找一个员工 你想招聘 好 这个时候呢 就招了一个专门 你的给的当你小助理的这样的一个人 谁来了呢 agent来了啊 右边这个 咱们把小助理请进来
好 请进来了之后 咱们来看 这就是小助理的见面了 我们管它叫做agent 对话 对吧 好 这个东西不叫skill啊 这个东西叫做agent 而是一个智能体 它是你的AI员工 那你
就可以让他学习或者使用各种各样skill 好 我们来举一个例子啊 这个员工呢 他本身已经具备了很多的技能点了 比如说 我们打开下面这个
我看这个界面怎么能放大一点 可以啊
好 来到这个右边
下方
我们点开这个skill 上面有几个现成了 但是有大概率不是你想要 对吧 咱们点开它
好 然后呢 我们再看啊 它这里有很多 但是你这样翻着有点费劲 是吧 咱们点skill 然后点击
全部
好的 然后呢 你就可以看到它
你招聘的这个AI员工 他现有的所有的这个技能了
那有可能呢 你让他做的这个事 刚好是他会的 对吧 比如说他要做这个脱口秀
刚好他会
好 那他就很开心 你就很开心的让他去做了 但是有的时候呢 你今天接到了一个新的项目 你发现呢
你的这个AI员工呢 他好像不具备你想要的这个能力
所以这个时候你就得训练他去把你想让他做的东西给做出来 对吧 这是咱们上节课有讲做一个3D动画的一个全流程 那今天咱们讲TVC的
好 OK 我们先来
学习第一种方式啊 就是直接使用
Skill来去做
那第一件事呢 如果我们想去做的话 你需要有一个产品
720到1080 我会直接直接生成1080 如果我需要1080的话 我肯定不会去做
生品的啊 我肯定会直接去生成1080
480就别想着放大能好 好不了啊 好不了一点 同学啊 你就别别那么想了
好不了一点的啊
来 我们现在先做第一件事 这个笔记我下课之后会同步到咱们的群里边 然后报了一次课的同学 我可以找一下助理老师去要 好吧
自己去要
OK 然后呢 我们来看一下
这是咱们今天前面讲过的 往后走一走
好 咱们进入到这个板块啊 就是AITVC广告制作的这样一个带链
那首先第一件事 咱们需要有一个全损照片
你拍一个也可以啊 生成一个也可以
那如果说你现在不想拍啊 你就想生成一个 你可以跟他说 帮我
给到大家一段这样的提示词 我就不生了 因为我已经生过了 咱们打开豆包
然后呢 你可以输入这样的提示词
现在就不用给他角色了 因为这张照片要求很低
咱要就是那种粗糙的 像是用手机拍出来的那种粗糙感啊
好
现在请你帮我生成一张
像是手机随意
拍摄的
这个产品
拍图
产品为一只
潮裤运动鞋或者一只运动鞋也行啊运动鞋
模拟
然后呢模拟手机
拍摄的
拍摄的质感
很不专业的
随意拍摄的感觉
当然现在就如果你不想生成的话
你完全可以自己随便拍一张对吧就举个例子我现在
哎我买了一个小蘑菇兔兔啊我现在想给他做一个
PPC广告是吧
那我就可以随便去拍一下
或者我买了一个这个小风扇啊我就可以随便拿手机
给他拍一下就结束了是吧咱们得到一个非常简陋的这样的一个照片
这个大家自己去码吧我就不把这个提示词给你们沾那里了啊就有点搞笑了
好那比如说咱们现在得到了一张这样的这个照片
这我用GPT生的啊这不是我拍的因为我怕
抖音判定为我正在做做真实产品的广告我就只好拍了一个啥产品都不是的假的啊这个虚拟
你出来的产品啊比如说我搞了一个这个鞋出来那今天呢我就想给这个鞋去做一个TVC的广告片
好那么接下来呢我就得到了一张这样的广告片对刚才这个提示词咱们还需要在后面加一句这个话啊比例为
比如说4:3
是吧
这样一个比例就可以了记得告他一个比例要不然正常生成出来他肯定是1:1的
好那么咱们一般情况下拿到一个非常简陋的产品的时候放到过去你需要招聘一个摄影师买一个单
单反相机是吧老贵了啊然后跑到客户那
左拍竖拍在找灯光石在打光
现在是完全不需要的咱们干嘛呢啊咱们就可以把这个鞋拿去生成品牌分析
一般情况下客户给到你一个这样的品牌的一个介绍啊我这里面提取出来了一些但是如果客户没给你
你又想有一个虚拟的品牌去练手
这里呢给到大家我们来虚拟一段提示词出来啊比如说
现在呢我们可以
把这个产品图给他建议大家使用GPT啊有GPT的用GPT没GPT的用豆包好吧
都可以
然后呢咱们
来我们输入这样的写词字把这两个都给他打进去啊图一
图一
为我的产品照片
产品照片
这里怕大家混淆我这里给大家换个产品吧咱们换个产品
就是到时候会把这张图给到你们我会一起放到文档里就是这张图啊你们
拿着我这张图去当一个参考的模板让他给你改就可以了
我现在换一个其他的产品我换个这个
换个这个啊这是有这种AI生的特效实拍图是吧
好OK
所以同学说老师我觉得生成的AI味特别重那是因为你不会写提示词啊我都能生成出来
这种一点AI味都没有的东西能看出来吧
好然后呢把这个产品介绍给他放进去
好我们现在这样去虚拟一个产品的介绍啊
图一是我的
产品照片图
照片图
我希望你能够模拟
作为啊你能够作为专业的产品
规划分析专家
为我虚拟
虚拟这个
虚
虚拟
这个养生糊的
糊
的产品信息
具体的形式
参考图2
中的描述
好这里我们要括号告诉他啊
仅
参考
什么呢
形式
和结构
板块
非
内容和产品
别到时候给我们做成运动鞋子了对吧
非内容和产品本身
好
为我
策划
生成
产品介绍
字数
也
和图2
差不多
好括号
或者是最后咱们说的注意
本次
紧
要求你生成文字
非
图像
好
叠到它
然后呢尽量用GPT啊
GPT的话会更贴近于我们
我带着大家去做的这个效果
OK
应该还能跟得上吧
嗯
有五个同学睡着了啊
好
OK我们来看一下哈
呃北顶养生壶看名字都给我们起好了叫北顶
专注精致居家饮水清养生场景是吧
都给我们策划好了啊
然后呢你就可以说
很好啊
请将
请将这些内容准确
无
无任何删减的
生成到一张图上
好白底
黑字
即可
OK啊然后呢
图片
图像比例为
43:4
走你
然后他就开始生图了是吧这一步我就不等他了待会咱们可以回来看一下
他可能就没有我们想象中那么快了啊
好那么大家可以用这个方法把我的这个运动鞋的产品的介绍可以改成任何一种
产品
去作为你们的虚拟案例去做
好那接下来咱们就做两件事啊第1件事呢就是把我们的这个产品介绍的这个图给他
拖到LibTV当中作为参考图
第2件事呢就是把我们这个运动鞋的实拍图拖进来我们作为参考图
OK
好的啊右边其实我们什么都不要加
什么都不要加
好那接下来咱们就可以去用这两样东西做广告了想想都觉得不可能老师这
还能这样啊
确认是能这样了
好那么我们在制作之前啊我们注意
现在有了两样东西之后不能直接生成因为你这个鞋太难看了这张图做的咱们需要去
去给他生成一个啥呢他的
三式图以及他的精修图
好那么这里呢我已经把提示词给大家写好了我们可以来看一下所谓的精修就是把这样的一个
看起来特别粗糙的实拍照片
给他改成一个看起来像专业的3D建模或者是精修啊这个美术精修之后的这样的一种效果我们使用这样的一段提示词
好
提示词在这里当时给大家站进来啊
咱们来看这里有一个产品精修对吧
好 我们来看一下这一段提示词保持外观颜色比例的一致性
修复产品的瑕疵优化光影专业的摄影品质整体达到品牌级的产品精修效果好
OK 然后呢我们直接啊在这
可以在我们的这个skill当中进行啊可以在这个里面去进行或者是我们这一步不在skill里面也可以啊咱们
干嘛呢我们在这
来
我们在这里拉出一个新的节点
点击这个加号松手
点击新建图片
然后呢我们在这里去写Ctrl+V
给它粘贴进来就行了
好我们先把agent关了暂时用不到啊
好我们来看一下保持产品外观颜色比例结构一致
产品在哪呢这个在产品的后面点一下的光标点击
at
at一下这个产品
好这一步是用不到你的产品介绍的
然后呢选择一个合适的
比例比如16
依然16:9就可以了然后清晰度2k啊然后你直接点击
生成
这一步我看我还要不要生我就不生了不浪费点数因为我已经生过了这个提示词绝对百分百没问题啊我我就是用这个提示词做的
好然后呢我把我这个精修之后的给大家
拉进来我看我放在哪了啊
哎我那张精修图
去哪了呢怎么只有这个彩色的了
镜号13
应该在我的录屏里呢我就把这个彩色的这个精修图拿进来吧
好那他就把这样的一张特别简陋的石骸图就给我变成一个精修的效果了大家看到了吧
就直接看起来特别像这种3D建模的感觉了
那接下来呢咱们就可以用这张精修图给它变成一个什么呢给它变成一个三式图出来
正常你生出来应该是一个白底的我这里就
懒得去重新生了不想废这个点数了啊我有一次是紫色的我就把它拖进来那个白底的我没有存在我的这个文件里
好那么有了这张之后我们继续啊
再用这张精修图出一个什么呢叫做产品资产啊叫做产品资产
当然可以用GPT了我现在只是不想打开GPT这一步我肯定是用GPT做呀因为省钱呢对吧GPT
对那个想冲GPT的你如果找不到人我这可以给大家发一个链接啊如果你们需要的话啊
因为
我一直在找那个人冲我觉得那个人
太贴心了我挺喜欢那个小伙的所以有的时候我就
帮他介绍一下你们如果需要的话158
他是啊就是如果你没有更便宜的你就找更便宜的如果你们自己有国外信用卡自己冲就可以了啊
这个也不一定非要找我你们想找谁找谁啊OK
好呃那接下来我们继续啊现在呢你他只有一个产品的正面肯定是不行的啊因为产品的背面
他的这个右边左边长什么样子谁也不知道
如果你直接拿这张图给AI去做TVC那可能到不同的镜头里他就穿帮了是吧所以接下来咱们需要做一个
这样的一个视图来给大家看一下完成的效果啊
这样的就是这个鞋左边长什么样右边长什么样啊他的这个正面长什么样背面长什么样
脚底板长什么样从上面看下去是什么样
咱们需要有一个这样的资产给到他
任何产品都是这个逻辑啊不一定非是运动鞋是吧
比如刚刚那个养生壶啊
或者这个电风扇呢都是可以的
需要你就问一下助理老师就行让他把那个链接给你
共享我一般不用共享共享太容易封号用不了几千封号还没售后
我一般是不共享的因为我觉得一个月158已经挺便宜的了要比我在LibTV里面
我LibTV生不了几张图就158了对吧
看你自己的生成量如果你量很大肯定是个人账号啊就如果说你量很小的话或者是玩
我觉得共享一下或者用豆包都可以了一分钱不用花
然后呢咱们接下来点击这个加号继续新建一个图片节点
我们要把这张图给它变成一个三式图出来啊
比如这三式图也可以16:9也可以是其他的比例
我们用这段提示词
这个也是我码出来了
保持产品外观移植性
生成正面侧面背面45度俯视各个角度啊咱们把这个
这这句提示词怎么复制一下注意啊这句提示词它必须是什么呢必须
要有这个
保持移植性这一句话要不然的话他就开始给你乱跑了是吧Ctrl+C
然后来到这这一步是可以用那个GVT的啊也可以用豆包的好Ctrl+V
然后呢产品外观这 add 一下这个运动鞋
好然后其他的地方就不用 add 了
因为咱们提示词里面已经写的保持移植性了对吧
我怎么讲讲的鼻子突然不同了好奇怪
好然后注意看
严格保持移植性它有的时候还是会有一定
程度的这种有变形的可能性
我们尽量保证它能一次重新
大家注意如果你升任何内容的时候只要抽卡超过三回一定是你的提示词有严重的问题
就别再抽了啊你就抽了三回还不行你
当然有一种情况就是设计logo
设计logo真的是你抽50次可能只有5个是好的
但除了logo以外其他的东西都不可以抽三次以上那一定是你提示词写的很烂就别再挣扎了赶紧改吧
好我们来看一下然后其他没有任何问题的话我们就直接生成选一个合适的比例比如说
16:9或者3:2都可以然后直接点击生成就行了我这就不生了然后这一步你生成出来之后
它长这样
它长这样看到了吧
就可以有一个这样的图像出来这个我应该是生成的16:9的看比例应该是
我就
不再反复的去生了要不然有点太浪费点数了我把这几个咱们需要用到的
所以到现在为止啊
这张照片也就是你的这个全损画质的实拍照片已经不需要要了
咱们就把后面的两个的给拿过来
那接下来咱们就三生万物了啊
一生二二生三三生万物
是吧我们拿这三张图去生万物
去生万物
好那接下来我们来讲两种方式
第一种方式呢就是我们直接用调用它的skill去做
第二种方式呢就是我们
手搓
TVC
用Conf UI不香吗
Conf UI你怎么用避免模型呢
小伙伴
Conf UI都被我淘汰了一年半了
不行确实不行
而且那个有的同学还得买线上算力或者自己买显卡
我觉得真的不好用
因为太干了
对之前你就不用三十图是吧
三十图是必须要用的
我们讲线下班教TVC的时候
我们线下的TVC是要讲整整一个星期的
就是肯定还是不一样,因为线下会详细的去拆
视听语言,一点点的去教视听语言,会真的学完之后像导演
你如果感兴趣的话可以去问崇利老师
我在咱们这个课里面不上连接的
感兴趣自己问
线下班适合于找工作的或者做自媒体的或者要做商业级项目的同学
线上比较适合于
爱好者或者是已经学完线下班的同学
是这样的
就是纯爱好你跟着老师的步骤做起来也是能完成的
但是如果你想自如的像利用视听语言
利用蒙太奇去原创的话是有点困难的
咱们今天有线上的同学线下班同学在听
可以告诉大家我的课怎么样
好
OK
来我们继续继续好那接下来咱们就可以用这三样东西去生万物了
那我们可以来给他第一句话了
我们来看一下这个步骤是吧
刚才呢我们已经进入到了
这部产品说明图刚才也教大家生了
我们看豆包这个怎么样出来了没有
出来了
你看
豆包是不是就有点诡异是吧
豆包生成东西它就完全跟GBT就比不了了
这是我用GBT生的里面一个错别字都没有
完全准确
你看豆包生的我真的是啥都不想说了全是错别字
气死我了
3比S4
比例啊中间在不明文字啊出现了一个
然后反正里面错别字特别多啊
高什么
加那后什么
反正错别字蛮多的
建议还是GPT吧好吧
反正也都是半会员
豆包是68块钱一个月
我还办了专业版的
因为我前段时间给他们做广告啊
办了专业版的
我做广告那天用的还挺好的怎么生个图全是错别字呢
真是太不给力了
本来想趁此机会给他
好好地宣传一波
这还
失败了
继续加油啊豆包
好
我来继续看啊
下一步就选择合适的Skill
OK我们
来手搓提示词
那接下来呢咱们就要开始了啊
咱们接下来就要开始了
现在请你
我们先进去看一下有没有TVC的Skill啊
咱们点击全部
我再来一遍啊走神了是不是
来点这个Skill
点全部进入到它的Skill商店
好然后我们搜TVC
这边有商业广告这一栏吗
进来了
看
哇这么多种TVC啊
看看有没有这个
特别适合我们的
比如现在是一个运动鞋
对吧哪个适合我们的高机能时尚风配饰
酷炫广告
手机手表不太适合我们
高奢感TVC打造国际化高级感TVC
我觉得这个可能可以用得到啊
咱们再来看极简科技感TVC这个可能也用得到
然后呢咱们看看还有没有比较适合我们的啦
复古电子产品这个肯定不适合我们
我觉得比较适合的我们来这个高奢感吧
我们来这个啊
看见他的这个样片
怎么说呢
还行吧
就还行吧
但是没有我想象中那么惊艳
肯定是跟手挫是比不了的
但是我们就先展示演示一下这个SKILL是怎么用的
好我们点击这个使用
OK咱们在前面说
请你
使用
谁呢就是这个高奢感SKILL
是吧咱们已经写出来了
OK
怎么还不能在他的后面
可以啊
请你使用这个高奢感SKILL
SKILL为我的产品
产品谁呢
at一下你张产品图是吧
点击他啊
然后呢制作
一条啊精致的
TVC广告片
稿片
广
稿片啊
我的产品
啊
这个信息
可
参考
谁呢再at一下产品信息图就这一张大家记得吧这一张产品信息图啊
好at一下我的产品信息图
好继续往后去写
然后括号啊紧
文字信息
非
视觉形式和排版
既然呢参考里面的文字信息就可以了千万别把
别把这张图当成我这个广告里面的一部分那就很尴尬了是吧
好然后呢我
我希望
我要求
我的要求是
广告的长度为
比如说
18秒是吧一个18秒刚好超过一条咱这样咱们比较能够直观的看到我的广告的长度为18秒
比例为什么呢啊比例为这个
16:9
9然后呢
清晰
度
为
720P这个一定要跟他说啊
好
请你
为我生成
请你为我生成然后呢直接
点击生成就可以了啊希望他这次不要给我
我一般情况下是比较喜欢第一次自己手挫
Skill的流程这样你比较可控他的成本
你用对方这个Skill你并不知道对方这个Skill他到底会生成几个
会生成几个节点会不会在生成节点的时候征求你的同意
就比较有这个心理负担啊就是自己去挫Skill的话就会比较的方便一点了
头像移到啊不好意思我又忘了这茬了
我给他移到这来这样可以了吧
这是咱们现在正在用Skill
坏了30图我漏了不好意思
我把30给漏了啊来大家注意啊
我先暂停一下吧暂停一下我们从从那个修改一下好好听听听
OK
不好意思啊
不好意思啦同学们完了取消取消取消取消
怎么就开始了呢
你看因为我没有@30图导致他开始给我生30图了就比较尴尬了啊
我们重新开启个对话好来
粘贴一个这个提示词我就不重新粘了在这个产品旁边啊
你再@一下这张30图
然后可以再写一下啊这个
我的产品是什么啊
为我生成然后我的产品
多视图
为
再@一下这张图
然后呢
注意
严格保持
产品一致心
好其实你这些东西什么都不写你直接@了这个
呃就是刚才咱们不是选中了这个skill他也可以直接给你生的啊只你写了之后他给你生成的就比较的
细致
但是有可能啊这个skill他的第一步就是生成30图有可能你给的30图他还会生成30图那就比较流氓了是吧
咱们看看他这次会不会给我们生成30图啊不一定但如果我们自己手搓的话他就不会的
看看他会不会生成30图他如果又生成30图那我就无能为力了只能说明他这个skill这么训练的
产品基础信息一定要以图片形式提交不能用文本形式吗可以
因为我你看他还是给我们生30图了这个就有点恶心了就是
因为你用他的这个
工作流其实他skill本质上是个工作流嘛你用了他的这个skill
他的这个skill里有这一步他就不管你给了他啥他还是会有这一步啊
所以咱们自己训练skill就不存在这个问题了对吧
然后那个同学说能不能不用不给他提供图当然可以了我之所以提供是因为你们真正在做项目的时候你们肯定会先有图的
明白吧你没有图你咋做项目那客户不可能连产品都不高你说给我做个广告
那他不有病吗是不是
这一步刚才对话的这一步是不消耗积分的但是他一旦开始升图他就会消耗积分的
他相当于在右侧给你变成了一个可以给你对话的机器人然后他代替你在左侧给你新鲜节点大家明白这个道理了吧你看
你点这个节点下面会有相应的
这个提示词然后还有相应的模型
他这个就是啥他直接给你选了这个模型了他可能想给你节省点成本因为他这个skill当时在训练的时候用的是这个模型
但如果你不想用这个模型的话你现在可以点取消然后把这个模型给他换成最上面的这个或者是在我们提出这个要求的时候
你就可以在这个下面的对话这可以选择模型偏好
你可以选择选择这个他就会
首先选择这个模型来给你生成图像了我刚才没有改你可以去改的
嗯第1张图就是你用豆包生成的那个咱不用那个图按个基本信息一定要用图片
信息给到LibTV吗可以不给啊
你看他这个生成的还不错的同学们
他是30图生成的不错的
但是我不太明白他为什么要生成
两个30图呢
下面是细节30图上面是产品30图我们就
试一下吧既然走到这一步了咱们就试一下
我们稍微的就
等他一等啊这里生了三个细节比如说
他的这个脚底板长啥样啊等等等等他这个但是
这是这个右侧这个有点不准确啊我还是觉得
建议大家还是我们首选这个
第一个模型啊首选第一个模型
你看他这个就有点不准去了我咱们换个模型再重新升一遍吧啊我觉得有点太难看了
咱们再来一遍换一个模型
他那个鞋帮那
东西给少了是吧上面这个30图还是比较准确的基本上没有什么问题
没有完全完全没有问题
手搓死给我咱还没讲呢
还没讲呢
其实待会手搓死给我不会讲的非常的详细的因为上节课已经比较详细的讲过但是我会告诉你怎么去搓我会讲我会讲的就是小白你们肯定听得懂这个不用担心啊
OK我们稍微的等一下
大家记得每周都过来因为咱们每一次学东西都是不一样的
然后你看它过程里面会问你一些问题
比如说产品
三个三十图已经升职好了接下来要确认几个关键信息比如说产品广告的目的
你是想介绍形象还是想促销是吧还是想强调它的卖点
OK还想要情感共鸣咱们就要
品牌logo收尾或者是我看看
然后呢制作的这个风格是什么啊这次就好很多了是吧
然后风格这个鞋底其实
还那样就这样吧
我只能说我觉得下面这张图就有点大可不必
因为其实有上面
这三个三式图我觉得就够了他这个skill还非得多给我生成出来一张
然后呢要实拍电影风格昏剪风格CG感我要第二种啊然后呢
情感故事类的故事类的演示类的我要这个演示类的
极限运动场馆
对吧电影风运动高级中性色电影风复古蓝调啊
等等等等如果这些都不是你想要的就可以直接去输啊咱就随便选了然后
模特的话亚洲女性
旁白的话无旁白无字幕强调视觉冲击力是吧
品牌slogan
赞无
让他自己去想吧提交
好然后呢他就开始帮我们去进行策划了
那为什么我其实更建议你自己去手挫skill的原因是因为
这整个过程你是可控的你是按照自己的逻辑去做的
并且呢他不会出现刚才这种情况啊就是
未经你的同意是吧就给你生成了两张多视图其实咱已经给他提供了图了但是他未经的同意又开始因为他这个skill的流程就是这个样子
好ok那接下来这个skill就帮我们去生成服装图人物图还有这个场景氛围图啊等等等等开始给我们进行生成了
好我们稍微的等待一会
咱们看skill里面的样片
直接点进去就看了点这个skill然后全部
每个都可以
比如点这个
哎这是他的生成出来的效果是吧长得有点像肖战
比如这个
这是他的效果
直接进来就可以点然后可以添加skill
好我们可以看一下给我们生成了点啥
我们生成了
这是用什么模型生的我看一下啊这是用midjourney的模型生的
这个是场景是吧
然后还有服装他给我们选了不同的模型啊场景的话他可能觉得midjourney生成的这种风格化的东西会更好一些
所以这一步他就给我们用midjourney的这个场景来给我们进行生成
好然后这个我们就稍微的等待一下就是一步一步跟着他去走啊跟着他去走然后就能得到最终的
这样的一个
影片了
好我们一边等他生成我一边来讲一下手搓的时候怎么去做的
我先给大家看一下我上一次啊就是
用Agent生成出来的这个效果大家可能都不记得了刚上课的时候给大家演示过一次是吧
稍微我们一下脱糖了同学呢困不困来来
把不困
不困的同学把不困或者是醒着打在公屏上好吗
因为我脱糖了我这个
怕大家觉得老师怎么又脱糖了
不满意怎么改呀不满意你就
在他这个节点这改呗比如说你这个节点不满意你就在这挑提日词点击生成就行了
你也可以在右侧跟他对话上开始盖
两种方式都是可以的
这是他生成的模特
一看就是那个寂寞模型生成出来了长得都一样啊你这这一步你如果用GPT或者nano不nana就不会出现这种情况是吧
所以大家注意啊生的时候
还是要告诉他一下用哪个模型的要不然就很讨厌啊
喜欢哪一个氛围
我想想啊我觉得我比较喜欢
这个
好那选择模特的服装我看看哪个比较好呢咱们就选择第一个
好提交
OK它就开始了是吧
非常的磨叽啊在这个过程里浪费了你很多的点数所以说第一次啊这个skill自己去训练
就不会有这个浪费了是吧你用他的那就是他官方人员去做的巴不得你
巴不得你多多做几张图用他的产品呢啊他就是这样的
好来我们看一下就是我的成篇长什么样子然后待会咱们就一步步点下去
就结束了啊然后我给大家讲一下自己怎么样去训练skill
困困的话掐自己大腿一下
来
我觉得好酷
ok啊然后给你们看一下这个
之前的这个工作流啊它有这样4个大家可以看啊有这么4个
节点他给我
通过这个工作流然后生成了这样的4个节点我们可以来看一下这是第1个
哎
这是
啊下面下面的4个啊黄神的
先来看一段
一个
5秒
啊这是工作流最最让
难受的一点就是他明明只需要给我生成两段就可以了他非要给我生成4段多赚我两份钱啊越想越生气是吧
因为我一点点短的生成的话就对一点啊
第二段
第三段
好然后呢第4段
他非给我生成4个5秒哇真生气是吧
然后呢
他最后给我做了一个这样的合成这个音乐是他自动生成的啊你看一下
选的是这个模式
这个他这里只有一个声音乐呢
效果还是不错的
然后呢他自动啊开了一个视频合成的节点然后就
最后就回来刚好看到这个样子了
这套花多少钱
比我自己手挫贵了1.5倍
就是我自己手挫可能比如说
举个例子啊我自己手挫的话是100块钱的他差不多就是150
我自己手挫的话肯定要比这个便宜一点的但是省事啊同学们
省了多少事呢
我觉得还是值得这个钱的啊
OK好啊然后我们看他下一步进行到哪一步了啊他还在他也在走咱就不管了啊他给我们把模特的30图生成好了
我看这次用的是什么模型啊
哎这个急梦的这个新模型看起来还不错比原来好很多了啊没有不至于那么把红脸了然后氛围图有了
好让他继续去思考吧
然后我大概跟大家说一下你们自己手挫的我们自己手挫工作流是怎么样去挫的对吧比如说还是
刚才的
这个图
这个图啊不是这个图咱们就直接
放这个
多视图吧
我直接放多视图
然后还有一个产品的
大图是吧咱们就需要这三样东西就可以了
好
这一次呢
我就不在右侧实操了因为等着他实在是太慢了咱可能就要脱糖到10点
我直接给大家去写提示词
你们就知道怎么样去做了啊
好
然后呢大家来看一下这是手挫的一个
流程
第一步就是先去设定你的剧本啊
设定你的剧本好我们先写一段这样的提示词
现在你是一名
专业的
资深的
专业的资深吧
TVC广告导演
导演
请你
先
分析我的
产品
好
我的产品及产品外
外观
及
产品信息
好
然后咱们就add这张图这张图待会我来实操一下啊
现在你是一名TVC导演分析我的产品信息
分析完毕后啊
请你回复
一
就这么的简单啊
分析完毕后请你回复一
无需生成任何的
图像
及内容
OK 咱们就把这句话先给他
因为现在你是在跟你的AI员工去对话对吧
然后呢我们展开这里的Agent
把它放
哎 这个界面怎么不能放大呢
哎 我一放大放大这个没办法了那只能这么小的看了啊
好 我们先把这个对话框给它清空这次我们不邀请任何的skill进来
我们直接啃出V
不能放大吗好难受啊你们看你们能看清吗是不是看不清
OK 这样可以了啊全屏之后可以了
好 然后注意啊看咱们的右下角啊
请你分析产品的外观
这个时候@一下你的这个产品的精修图还有你的多视角的图
以及产品信息@一下你的产品信息图
然后分析完毕后请回复于无息生成任何的图像及内容我们直接给他发送
时间就是金钱
是这个意思啊
提示词不能一次生15秒嘛可以的你跟他说只仅可以建立一个视频节点就可以了好回复1了OK接下来咱们继续
待会我下课之后会把这一串咱们手撮的提示词也给他
给到他啊我现在就现场手撮了
好继续啊让他给我们创造一个TVC的剧本
好的啊现在请你结合你的分析结果及产品外观形态
形态为我策划一步
好多少秒呢比如说15秒
时长的啊TVC
蝉形广告
然后你可以给他一些详细的要求比如说
这个视频的
比例为
16:9
我希望你可以给他一些要求也可以什么都不写啊
我希望这个
这个视频的
这个是这个广告
为快节奏影片啊快节奏
影片
然后呢可以给他一些起氛围比如说
时尚
酷炫
简约
的风格
OK给他这些就可以了然后
给到他啊为我策划一部广告
请你先为我生成广告
广告的
啊这个
脚本策划
好可以先给到他一个这样的过程
OK看着C
然后呢继续给他看着V
好给了他
让他去策划脚本吧
这一步还没有开始生图对吧
等到生成生图那一步就不每一次真正的去生了因为太磨叽了
好咱们来看一下刚才这个怎么样了
确认直接并生成两个Clip
好提交
他给我们两个两串
看到了吧两个应该会给我们生成两个视频节点
一个两个
一个是9秒
第二个也是9秒
然后呢就给我们合成完了
差不多这样的一个流程
好然后呢我们来看一下这个之前完整的这个我就给它关闭掉了
OK看非常快的一个速度啊咱们刚才刚切到那个里再回来
已经策划好了
核心的创意广告语
Step into the future
就是迈向未来冲向未来
核心语言速度感
霓虹爆发未来都市快切剪辑
毕竟是5秒到0.5秒到2秒啊非常的快哎这个就刚好是受到自媒体平台用户欢迎的一种节奏感
不需要给写受众群体吗
你有这个要求就写我现在就不写了因为我就想简简约一点你可以写啊比如说给什么样的人去看咱们现在主要就是把这个流程跑一遍
你们自己在做具体项目的时候客户肯定会有他的具体要求你写进去就可以了好吧
然后呢咱们继续啊这一步已经完成了是吧
是否满意将开始生成正式的TVC广告视频
好如果你满意你可以继续让他生成那如果你怕被他牵着鼻子走那你下一步最好是要牵着他的鼻子走
好然后我们怎么去牵着他鼻子走呢现在分镜已经有了是吧
好那么接下来你就可以去生成看有没有关于人物的
城市街头年轻人怎么怎么样啊然后这里面其实没有非常刻意的去体现
人物的形象对吧那么你可以继续啊分镜策划这一步其实已经有了咱们就可以把这个
放进来啊有的时候他这一步给你的是故事有的时候他会直接给你分镜那这次他已经把我们分镜给我们生成好我们就不需要继续生成了
好资产固整理
很好对吧
很好啊现在请你
这个提炼
提炼出这个TVC广告中的
角色
场景
资产
并生成
这个
标准
标
准的
叫什么呢
这个视觉设定图
方便我
方便我后续进行
先的制作
好
然后呢我要给这个如果大家这一步特别不放心怕他又浪费你的点数你干嘛呢你这一步先让他生成提示词
明白了吧
设定图
的
提示词
好然后后面你跟他说一下啊就是
注意
本步骤
紧
生成提示词不要
生成图像
我告诉你为什么要这么样去做啊咱们先给他
或者c然后可能为这是一个非常节省成本的方式啊
好他一边生成咱们一边看一下刚才的这个发生了什么来看一看啊还没出来
还没出来那我们就先等等吧
好
然后你看
提示词出来了他出来的是
英文呢我不想要好吧OK咱们给这样的改一下哈我需要
我需要你生成的是
中文提示词
好吧他已经开始了咱们就
等他生成完吧生成完了我们让他给我们改一下
嗯相当于做了一个工作流的模板后面的TVC对了就是这个意思
你刚才看到的他们训练好的TVC也是
他们官方的人或者是一些小伙伴们自己训练上来的让别人去下载官方现在拿出2000万
然后去奖励这些上传特别好用的skill的人
然后呢生成的中文提示词
OK让他给我们改我们要中文的提示词
倒点VC水
你们也可以喝一口水
OK
上完无灶啊
出来了是吧
好
这一步有什么用
我来给大家详细的讲一下啊
这一步如果说你
让他直接生了
就很糟心
因为他可能
生成的不太对劲
然后呢就给你整一对错的
你就浪费点数是吧
好
这一步有一个好处就是
他现在生成的都没有什么问题了
你就可以继续哈
好的
请你先
帮我生成
第1个
角色
好
这样是不是就很棒是吧
你就可以
可以去看
还有一种方式就是
第1种方式就是你直接点击这个
帮我生成第1个角色
其他的先不要生成
第2种方式呢就是你看他这个提示词没问题之后
自己在这边啊
直接
图片然后呢你新建一个节点
等一下我整理一下啊
另一个方式就是你直接在这新建一个节点
好然后呢你把这个提示词给他复制过来
怎么复制不了呢
还复制不了啊那就没辙了是吧你只能把这
几个图给他逗包然后
粘在下或者手输入一下都可以啊亚洲
亚洲男性这里有一个什么好处呢就是
你在这输入了之后你可以在下面选模型
上面这个他就开始
帮你替你选模型了看了吧啊这次他替我选的还行啊如果他
没有替你选的话你有可能给你选择你不喜欢的模型还有一种方式就是
比如说我们刚才这段提示词啊请你帮我生成第一个角色
写完之后
你可以在这
哎然后呢模型偏向你可以选择他
哎这样就不会给你乱选其他的模型
这是第一个角色但是我们会发现在没给我们生成三式图是不是好
所以就是说我们先生成啊这个提示词的好吃又在于这
比如说你看了这一段这个提示词你觉得不满意的话你可以手动加入或者修改说人物的标准资产必须得有三式图
然后他再给你生成就不会浪费点数了大家能够明白这个道理吧
OK比如说这一步我就懒得生成三式图了比如说咱们就这样了啊这个就是我们的人物的一个
设定了
好然后你就继续跟他去说啊接下来的一步我就不生了再生就太过浪费点数了因为我已经做过一次了好然后呢
继续啊这个
提示词然后后面加括号吧中文中文提示词
请你啊帮我
生成第1个角色人物
好这里可以给他加一个啊必须为标
标准的人物设定图
包括
这个三视图
及
多角度
视图
好这里应该还加一个啊加一个什么东西呢加一个人物的近景形象
包括人物近景
近
景
形象
三视图及多角度的视图OK
然后呢啊没有问题的话
好的啊
请你帮我生成
所有的
资产
图像
然后他就会把人物的和场景的全部都帮你归纳好生成出来然后就可以帮你生成视频了
好
这一步结束了之后呢咱们就直接啊可以开始让他制作成片
然后就好的啊请你继续帮我制作
完整的
这个
成片效果或者是如果不放心的话
那咱们还是让他先出一步提示词啊好的
请你结合前面
你
做的分镜策划
以及我以及生成的
资产库
图像
帮我策划我
这个
策划这个分镜
视频
分镜提示词
好这里你可以看一下你的这段视频一共有多少秒比如说你这段视频一共只15秒的话你就可以用一段生成出来
如果16秒的话就要拆分啊
每一段
然后可以告诉他的视频拆分
为
两个
片段
进行
生成
和
策划
每个
片段
包含多个
分镜头
对吧
可以让他去策划
现在
请你先策划
两个
片段
的
视频
生成提示词
提示词的形式要按照标准的
AI
导演
分镜头
策划的方式
方式进行撰写
包括
但无限于
镜号
秒数
对吧一个镜头多少秒啊然后景别
运镜方式
镜头
这个比较专业了是吧镜头运动
然后呢
镜头内容
镜头内内容人物对白
音效
及背景音乐
OK这样写就可以了如果还有其他的要求比如说什么光源啊什么样的一个特殊的方式都可以去写
给他这一段
那么他就会帮你把每段视频生成提示词
给他给你策划出来啊我们都可以先先试一下啊我现在暂时先不生成其他的图了咱们就直接给他这一段看他怎么会给
给我们好看一下刚才那个生成好了没有了好了来我们看一下啊这是刚才用他的skill做出来的
怎么声音这么小
嗯这么小的声音吗好奇怪
哟但是声音很小我不知道大家能不能听到
还不错啊
最后一个镜头有点傻是吧
最后一个镜头感觉傻傻的哈
我来看一下前面其实还行
一直到这其实都还可以
到这也不错啊
尤其是这几个镜头我觉得还是不错的
好就是最后这个女生站起来这块我觉得就有点有点呆了哈就是大家
如果生上完之后对这个镜头不满意的话
你可以在
可灵或者是用这个C弹小窄5单独的把这一个单镜头给他生成一下
是可以的啊怎么样去
修改这个单镜头我给你们去演示一下哈比如说
现在这个镜头你觉得特别傻
你觉得这个镜头特别傻然后呢你就点击这个截取当前针
哎他就出来这一针的画面了
然后呢你把这一针拉出来新生成一个视频的节点
然后把这一一个镜头的提示词在这写一下
直接去生成就可以了啊然后呢时间你就可以把它限制到最短
然后单独去生成完了之后混减到那个里面就可以了啊这个就是在简易里面自己去减一下了
嗯卡点卡的平他卡点卡的其实还行就是这个站起来那个动作有点有点傻傻的
这个文档课后当然可以发给你们了这个就是给你们准备的就是
学习可以啊但是不要拿去讲课好吗
求求你们了啊不要这么干啊
我都是注册个版权的我实在是不想给某些人打官司啊
觉得没意思
好来看一下我刚刚没有把资产全部都生成完但是我可以给你看一下
今天脱糖时间比较久啊大家还受得了吧
干脆这个镜头不要
好主意
我觉得还是不错的啊这个这同学很极致是吧我不生了我直接不要了
好咱们来看一下
片段一啊镜号什么什么样子的
第一个镜头第二个镜头
第一个镜头什么样子的第2个镜头什么样子的第3个镜头什么样子的第4个镜头看每一个都给我们策划的很好第5个镜头第6个镜头第7个镜头第8个镜头
好然后呢就告诉他啊
还不是分两个片段吗
然后呢就现在
请你
帮我我直接这这个咱们就不生了同学我不想浪费这个点数了
我直接告诉大家后面后面就剩两步了啊完全
就绝对的就只剩两步了
好然后呢第4
前面的都还能听得懂跟得上吧同学们我们现在讲的是
刚才那个是纯自动的咱们现在这个是手挫半自动的啊
下一步生成
视频
生成视频
好那这一步咱们就直接跟他说
好的啊现在请你先帮我生成第1个
视频
片段
紧线
啊紧
注意啊
必须
在一个节点
中
生成
生成啊
生成完毕
啊禁止分为多个节点
分为
多个
节点
啊要不然他非常讨厌啊
禁止分为多个节点
那其实如果你是小白的话你就可以看一下人家这个分镜是怎么写的可以去模仿可以去学习啊
好这个给他比较清楚
如果我对
本次
生成的内容较为满意
会
继续
让你生成
下一个镜头
这个好处是啥同学们你就不会浪费点数啊你按照我这个方式去升你基本上就跟你自己手撮浪费的点数是一样的
消耗点数是一样的不叫浪费了
你用他那个就你不小心啊钱就哗哗哗的就没了
是吧你就一个一个让他出提示词生一个出提示词生一个那其实本质上跟你自己在生是一样的而且会更省事一点大家明白这个逻辑了吧
嗯还是手撮的好哎是的是的啊就纯自动的你一不小心就那啥了就浪费了就花钱了啊
一不小心就花钱了之前还有人我说老师我能不能用龙虾去控制用codex直接控制给我生视频
啊现在他暂且说他就不能控制LibbTV他就算能控制LibbTV你敢吗你睡一觉醒来发现你充了一万块钱没了然后生成出来一堆屎
那肯定不行啊啊OK然后呢如果比较满意的话好的
不错啊请你继续完成下一个镜头
好这些完毕了之后继续啊生成成片
合成合成为
成片这一步我就不手动进行因为它生成的实在是太慢了啊好我们来看一下下一步咱们可以这样去说
好的啊请你将
前面生成的
两个片段
合成为
完整的TVC广告成片
适配
并
啊并
合理适配
合适的
背景音乐
OK
然后注意
剪辑的节奏
要
达到专业级
并
有
一定的
啊
这个小巧思是吧这咱们就自己加了啊小巧思
和
节奏感
这个你就随便去加加一个形容词就可以了好然后他就给你生成完成片直接下载就行了最后一步啊训练skill的这个过程
好的
训练skill
好这一步
大家直接按照我这个结构去写就可以了之后你训练任何一种skill你都可以按照我这一句提示词去写啊
来咱们来写
你感觉你在上语文课
确实本质上
现在AI其实就是对于语文好的人非常的友好
大概消耗多少积分
跟你自己手挫
如果你按照我这个手挫的方式去做的话跟你自己手挫消耗的积分基本上是完全一样的
多顶多多了几十个点
没有太大的区别基本上没有区别
训练Skill
现在
现在请你将
我们前面的对话过程
及生成结果
训练为可
复用的Skill
Skill的名称为
什么呢
叫做AI
或者叫做TVC
创作助手
就叫这个名字就可以了
我希望
下一次
我只需要提供
产品图和
介绍资料
你就能够帮我
完成
创作的全流程
好 这样咱们就把Skill
训练好了
比如说咱们前面已经训练好了
你就把这一段C
CV
粘在这里直接给他
然后下一次呢你就可以在这个
这有个Skill
这有个我的对吧
如果你自己训练Skill
你就可以在这个里面找到你训练好的Skill
可以反复的去使用
也可以分享给其他的人非常的方便
OK这就是
咱们今天讲到的一个全流程
这个Skill的这个成片我就不再生成了
因为我已经生成了两个成片了
我觉得就没有必要了
流程跟那个是一样的
这节课超级值
你去别的机构他不收你个五六千的能给你交这个吗
一点都不夸张啊
你们可以去问一下
别人如果收几百块钱他讲的绝对不是这个
别人收几百块钱大概率每个星期给你讲的一模一样的东西
然后逼着你再买个贵的课
如果有广告客户找过来
按照老师手挫的工作理由可以交工的吗
看他给多少钱同学
他给多少钱就给他多少质量的东西
明白吧
就如果说他只给了你五百块钱
只给了你一千多块钱三千以内的
你就用这个方式给他做
如果人家给了你
大几万十几万
你就用手挫的方式做吧
那肯定质量还是不太一样的同学
那质量还是不太一样的
我刚才开课的时候给你们放的那个
那是手挫出来的
那个质量还是不太一样的
包括我们线下班
我们会交一个星期的TVC
那个质量肯定也跟这个是不一样的
早上鸡份白花了
你也不晚
你提前两个星期还没这功能的
说了三节课装Kodax
你这个不算夸张的
前几个有一个线下班同学跟我说
他之前被割了韭菜了
去别地方花了五万块钱
然后前三天你知道学什么
前三天教他怎么装梯子
对说前四月课装梯子
我这好多线下班的学员都是在其他的地方就是
贼啦受伤啊
然后到我这来被安抚了一下
就是这样的
你们可以看我最近那个就语泛AI的那个抖音号
我们有一个公司号一个品牌号有采访的一些线下班的同学
那说的真的都是大实话我们可没有拖啊
OK我们今天的这个干货先讲到这
然后我跟大家说一下就是这个笔记啊
今天报了19块钱我觉得课不错的
可以记得找助理老师报一下全年的咱们每节课都是不一样的
我不可能讲一样的因为每节课都有试听的人
但没办法
有可能下节课还有很多同学第一次来人家一听每节课都讲的一样的不骂人了是吧
不会那样的哈就是这个这个笔记我待会下了课
我待会讲完所有的干货之后想休息同学体现休息我还是要介绍一下我的系统课的
因为要8月10号开班了嘛还是要介绍一下的
这个等我下了课之后我给你们发群里
好吧这已经咱们现在都脱糖了
一个小时了今天这个确实是有点有点干了啊
人都变少了我看见一般我讲这个
我讲课一般是没有人走的今年人走的说明就是难度有点高了可能是
然后这个我下课之后会给大家下一节课咱们讲咱们下节课应该还是讲影视
然后再下一节课我给大家讲电商设计啊就是电商的这个全案
电商的全案就是这一套全案详情业详情业海报
和模特图这些全部东西是怎么设计出来的
然后还有详情业我看这个详情业我没存吗
我看一看啊
详情业这我做每一条视频都这么的麻烦看到了吧
这是主图
最后搓出了一整条的这个详情业就直接能在淘宝上架的那种详情业
想学同学记得下下次一定要来下一次我大概率会讲影视的东西
有可能是AI脱口秀
有可能是AI的这种高品质的短片
因为很多同学还是想把那个导演台仔细的研究一下我可能下一节会讲导演台或者是脱口秀
看情况也可能会用会用导演台讲脱口秀
回放就在你们的上课链接里面都可以看的
今天还在手搓
你想做品质非常好的还是要手搓的同学
我们线下班同学来了我也不会让他们这么去搓的我会让大家去手搓的
手搓出来那个质量
AI目前还是比不了的
明白吧
想学脱口秀是吧
行
那这样啊同学们就是
没有系统学习需要的同学你们可以休息可以下课了
然后我接下来会介绍一下系统课
不要觉得我在卖广告
我只针对想听的同学我会介绍一下
不想听的你们就可以下课休息睡觉然后明天
做一下我们下节课见就可以了
本周还有一次
直播答疑啊大家记得来是乐意老师给大家答疑
非常贴心啊乐意老师是我们所有老师里面
最有耐心的老师
当然能看回放了
你回头点今天的这个那个链接你就可以看回放了
短剧的课什么时候讲早就讲过了短剧是咱们以前讲的漫剧之前的讲过n多遍了回去看回放吧好吧
咱们老以前讲过的我就不想反复的去讲了
之后如果有了新方法我会讲上节课咱们讲就是3d的动画3d的漫剧可以看下之前的课上的回放
这个课不是系统课我说一下如果你想靠AI找工作的话上这个课你是找不了的啊就是想找工作的话一定要来学系统课的
不是我可以让你买更贵的课是因为不同的课程它的
内容价值和服务肯定是不一样的系统课的价格是19,800他有他贵的道理啊
OK那么接下来我就要介绍一下我的那个另外的一个产品了没需要的同学可以休息下课了好吧
我的课上也不会上链接的这么贵的课也不会有人现场报名对吧
就是感兴趣的我就介绍一下不感兴趣的就不用听了或者想自学的你也可以看我这客人构架什么样子的
OK然后我我那个介绍的页面我还没打开我还得打一下啊
好想学系统课的我现在可以抠个想我看有几个人想然后我想我给大家来介绍一下
这个课里有啥
从第五期开始我们做了一个升级因为现在AI生成影片大家会发现其实还蛮简单的但是为什么很多人做完之后就是不火
重点就在于你不会找选题找方向不懂自媒体的逻辑不会写
不会写剧本
所以从第五期开始我们加入了剧本剧本创作的一周的课程啊整整一周
那么你也可以做爆款了
并且呢这个系统课程它是有长达半年的所有的老师的
EV1的自媒体陪跑的就是这半年里面你做的每一条自媒体的选题
你的这个大纲你的脚本你的成篇都可以一条一条的让我帮你去过啊直到赔到你能够起号为止
当然如果你半年之内你就是不起号你也懒得做那就别怪我了
但是从我这个角度只要你做我就绝对会有耐心的非常快的去给你知道回复你的
想
都啦
在B站上刷到一份提示词内容是告诉AI你的需求然后加入这句话
所有的一句话能解决的事都是骗局
就是我还是那句话啊学东西不要去
自媒体平台里面去学自媒体平台它不是用来学习的
它的本质上是用来引流的大家能够明白吧我这就
咱们闭起门来我就这么跟大家直接说就是用来收广告费
以及引流的
因为我自己也做自媒体的内容自媒体的内容它里面有很多
剪辑掉的东西比如说我为了完播率对吧现在抖音最看重的就是
看率和收藏率
还有五秒跳出率那如果我在整个的过程当中有一些步骤是对于我的完播率有影响的我可能就把它剪辑掉了
但是这个过程我不会在我的
咱们的社群课里也不会在我的线下系统班里面
去给它剪辑掉它肯定是存在的所以大家如果说真的想学东西肯定是来我们课里面去学不管是今天这种课还是我们线下课
OK那接下来我就详细的介绍一下这个整套课的一个
详细的一个大纲和内容感兴趣同学可以了解一下
那这套课的整体的价格是一万九千八
非常物超所值
目前来说我在全世界不能不敢吹这个牛啊但是在国内我感受我的学生作业绝对是排在前列的
整体的一个学习的流程是23天的一个时间一共是四周原来是三周我们现在因为这个编剧的这件事情非常重要所以我们就专门加了一个星期的课去
教大家怎么样去写剧本
所以课程也涨了一些价格啊那绝对是值得这个价格的
那之前学过现在班同学如果想恶补这块你也可以单独的就是补个差价把这块再学了也是可以的啊这个看大家自己的需要啊你自学也可以啊自己去琢磨也可以
OK那我们可以看一下
这个呢是
第一周的课程那第一周的课程是一个打基础的过程
首先先学习TVC以及视听语言啊那么系统学的话你就需要像
电影学院里面的学导演系的学生一样去学了
那这里呢就会先教大家如何去认知视听语言比如说我们刚才写分镜的时候的
景别
视角
构图
第一周我们先不学蒙太奇啊不学那么复杂的镜头组接我们先把单镜头怎么样去策划提示字怎么样去
写如何去
自如的手搓提示字就像我一样今天说这话同学们我讲后面后半部分的课
我完全是没有准备的
但是我依然能给你搓的非常的准确这就是功夫
我自己现在比如说我现在抖音开了一个直播我就能现场给你搓一篇影片出来
之前我做了一个教程有一个人说我的第一句跟他特别戏还过来说我抄袭他我一看除了第一句说的那句话是个人都能想出来以外
其他的跟他毫无关系非说我抄袭他然后我就跟他说我说你敢不敢开一个直播咱们现场写脚本了
他不敢他不敢但是我敢就是我是有这个功夫的我也会把我这个功夫交给你们
然后呢第2天开始我们开始进入到这个视听语言的进阶
包括这个图像一致性的控制基本基础的一个蒙太奇然后去做美术设定集啊这里面会详细的去分析品牌
今天我教大家的是用AI分析品牌但是我们线下学习的话我会教你们如何去分辨AI生成东西准确与否以及自己如何在品牌中提炼核心的卖点啊OK
然后呢还会有这个第3天我们学习这个资产库的一个搭建里面包括符画道人生音效音乐怎么样去生成怎么样去组接
然后呢动态视频的一个生成第5天就是一个成天的制作了
前5天你就会做出来一个非常精致的TVC广告片
我们第4期刚刚结束大家如果想看作品的话可以找助理老师去要一下我们这期同学的作品但是我们会打码给你不可能直接给你原片啊打码并且降低一下清晰度给你因为这个版权是属于同学的啊
OK我们不能乱去给你们去使用OK那但是大家可以去看一下带了水印和打码之后的也依然非常的精彩
那还有呢就是第六天啊第六天我们会学习简单的PS批图简单的图有时候还是需要去批的啊如果你什么都用AI有的东西有的图他是控制不了的哈然后第六天会教大家去搭建一个带货视频啊如果想做电商的同学想做带货视频的这一天会教大家做一个这种可以复用的工作流搭建出来之后可以一键去生成啊OK这个是我们说的前一周学习的东西就是打基础的一个东西啊为什么把TVC放在最前面
因为TVC它没有特别复杂的剧情所以你在去做蒙太奇的时候就没有那么高的要求了啊所以第一周你就会做出来多个非常漂亮的原创作品了
9月4号捷克 捷克时间我还真没算呢可以问下助理老师我这是数学不大好
对男的就是怎么把控节奏是这样的哈如果你只是来如果你只是想学软件你
你一分钱不用教我同学啊就来我这不是来学软件的软件有什么必要花钱学呢如果现在哪个培训班说了你你报了名之后我教你怎么用LeaveTV我真的只想
把拉黑并且送他放一个屁经典的放一个屁是吧
那种东西你直接看我抖音视频都能学会你有必要报班吗来这学的就是一个真正商业级的一个落地方法以及老师对于流量
对于媒体的一个把控帮你陪跑旗号啊帮你去找到工作
是这样的一个过程啊
OK
那么第2周呢就是开始学剧情片了学剧情片之前咱们会先学蒙太奇
我们会
这里讲蒙太奇我来说一下老师哈就是前面开课是我然后
乐意老师是常年当
这个执行导演的非常厉害很多非常知名的TVC广告是乐意老师带着项目组做出来的啊
然后呢第2周开始我们进入到稍微进阶一些的蒙太奇的组织
那如果你关注过影片你就会知道所有的视频当中
最难剪辑的你们知道是啥吗
就是综艺节目
那给大家去上这个课的老师
跑南都看过吧
跑南
还有峰位
就是现听峰那个峰位啊
然后还有那个叫什么王牌对王牌的后期总监
你们现在叫上名字的非常知名的
呃这个这个
综艺节目的总监基本上都是大宝老师
啊所以
纯粹的纯粹非常纯粹的干脆的一个大咖啊
我会给大家讲这个部分
所有的
镜头拼接当中镜头衔接当中最难的就是就是
综艺节目啊然后大宝老师就是干这个的他来给你们讲蒙太奇
够有资格吧同学们
你们平时其实是见不到这样的老师的说实话啊
OK然后呢接下来是配音和配乐的一个
能力
然后学完这些基础能力的进阶之后
咱们就要开始学
故事片了
前面咱们讲的蒙太奇不知道什么是蒙太奇
我们可以理解为镜头镜头
之间怎么去组接
不同的镜头
用不同的方法去组接
它就会产生不同的情绪和不同的情节
大家明白吧
非常的有意思啊
到时候我们会做这个蒙太奇的训练
大家这一天过得可开心了
然后
第二周第三天
我们开始进入到2D漫剧
的制作了
然后是3D漫剧从0到1的
完全的一个原创的过程
这一部老师会给你提供原创剧本的
就是大家不用担心跟上期同学重复
每一期的剧本都是不一样的
OK 然后呢
我们语泛AI是有专门的编剧老师的
我们是有专门的编剧老师的
专门给大家去研发这些剧本
然后呢
第三周
有点想打嗝
第三周我们就进入到难度更加进阶一些了
这所有的剧情片当中
其实仿真人剧
它的要求是最高的
也就是写实真人剧情
我们做的不是那种非常劣质的
那种诚挚的那种
那种东西啊
我们做的肯定要比那个精致的多啊就是能够你发布在抖音都让人看起来很惊艳的那种作品
然后呢是
真人短剧啊真人短剧的话也是大宝老师来进行授课的
然后MV也是大宝老师来进行授课的你们都可以找那个助理老师要一下本期的作业非常的惊艳啊我觉得每一期都要比上期更好一点
一个是
呃就是同学们的这种
热情很高涨啊这一期还有就是我们确实
走到这一期那个模型的能力要比之前
要强一些了说实话
那模型他也在进化啊所以效果是一起比一起好我还是
非常开心的
然后所有的前面我们做了非常非常多的这种原创影片之后呢咱们就进入到了自媒体的部分
自媒体你不可能在这学习两天就起号了同学们就不要有这种天真的想法啊
这两天是学啥的呢学的是起号的方法
养号的方法以及分析对标以及写出你的第一篇稿子的方法
这个已经非常干了同学们就正常情况下你学这两天的这个东西你得去其他机构交至少一万六
然后赔跑可能要16万
13到16万左右你们可以去那些那些交自媒体的一些
专门的机构去问一下就知道了他们的那个
就光光教我这两天的这些东西他都能收你一万多
因为啊我在这两天说的每一句话
都是我血和泪的教训
大家知道吧就血和泪得出来的可能我花了上百万我
我吃到的亏我得出的经验我会在这两天集中的教会你们
然后
在接下来的半年里啊你可以根据前面学到的技能加这两天学到的旗号方法
和养号方法还有找对标写文案找脚本找找这个找选题的方法
然后去请你的自媒体账号
当然有同学有这个需要有的没有啊有同学是为了就业的那也是没有问题的
这套课最低标准就是找到工作
大家明白吧就如果说我只是为了让你们找到工作
那也太好教了啊就是我你学完第一个星期你做东西就能找到工作了
咱肯定要精益求精对吧咱肯定要比自己的竞争对手要长并且要考虑到未来半年和一年的竞争力你不能说我现在就混到一个公司里面啊很多城市公司很好近的
混到一个公司里面混进去了之后半年之后因为我不了解视听语言我不了解蒙太奇结果被干掉了
我不希望从我们这里出去学生是这个样子的啊所以肯定要扎教大家很扎实的东西
嗯
课程是助教怎么可能是助教老师上课呢
课程是主讲老师上课啊我们一共有三位主讲老师
然后辅导老师也是非常厉害我待会给大家去介绍
然后第四周是我们最后一天是一个那个
就刚才比如刚那个东西是助教老师我刚跟你们说的跑男的总监那是你们的主讲老师啊
是直接在课里面给你们讲课并且给你们去
一点点抠你们作业的老师
这跟社群肯定是不一样的因为你来到线下学习的话我是在现场盯着你的时间轴一点一点让你改的那个
作业的精致度那肯定是社群课比不了的同学
OK
说到放屁字觉得淡住了你好恶心哦
第四周咱们是这一期新加进来的这个是
必须要加进去的为什么因为现在
做好的效果已经不足以让你起自媒体的账号了
已经不是2023年2024年了
2025年了今年2026年了
平台更看重的是你的选题能力和你的
编剧能力
然后
选题和编剧能
决定你视频70%能不能火的概率
大家知道吧我做视频的时候也是这样的我们每个星期四我们都要
我整个的团队都要开选题会的
一开开整整一下午光选题要开一下午的会呦
所以你就知道选题和剧本
这个东西是最重要的啊就是
包括之前给大家去分享的那个时光故事馆
大家还记得吧
他的他的视频做的并没有很精致但是因为他的选题和剧本非常好所以他每条视频都是爆火的
线上怎么学线上可以学的线上学的话就是
价格是完全一样的因为我们的服务和课程质量是完全一样的
而且线上线下各个各的好处线下就是我能一个一个时间轴一点点给你抠
线上的好处就是指导你的老师可就不止一个了
所有讲课老师都在去里面
可能会同时回答你啊就是这样的就是各有各的好处所以价格是没有任何变化的价格是完全一样的不会
不会便宜啊不会便宜这个大家
老师我线上学都便宜点便宜不了一点啊
因为我认为这个课他值这个钱
好吧我从来不去骗人不去矿人但是我也不愿意自己的劳动成果
得不到相应的回报啊
OK然后第4周呢是这个
编剧课程
这个课程的大纲我在
上课之前是绝对不会拿出来给别人看的
为什么呢因为
我这两年已经被其他的机构快给我抄哭了啊就是我
做一点东西我出一个大纲他们就抄一点我出一个
他们抄一点
之前
我做这个三个月设计课他们做三个月设计课啊我做18天的视频课他们也做18天视频课啊连这个课程大纲价格都跟我
都跟我模仿是吧
我觉得很讨厌啊所以
我在这期课开课之前我绝对不会公布我的大纲的
我不想让其他机构的人过来抄袭我OK
但我开了班的那一周你们就看到了
好吧
信任我的同学你你也不不需要提前看到大纲因为了解我的同学都知道
呃很多同学是从2019年就跟着我学习的
呃从那个时候开始很多同学就是我我出一个课他们就买一套课的原因是因为哪怕我没出这个课他都会说老师你能不能研发一个这个课因为他们比较信任我他们知道我对于
教育这行是非常有敬畏之心的
我绝对不会随随便便的去研发一套课出来的啊所以
嗯这个部分是就是这个样子的啊那么这个我们新增的这一周课程学习完之后呢
大家就可以自如的去编写自己的故事剧本啊啊那也比较容易
而且这里面我会融入关于自媒体的一些
思路啊不是那些纯粹的那种老派的剧本科是
呃
自媒体相关的一个剧本科啊当然这个底层逻辑你也可以去编
其他的长剧或者电影都是一样的
嗯
对抄袭是最恶心的行为没办法真的是没办法
我为什么现在不做纯粹的线上课程就是
闲鱼见吗
没意思啊真的没意思
所以我就不做纯粹的线上课程了辛辛苦苦讲半天啊闲鱼见
线下班他闲鱼见不了啊他没有办法闲鱼见
因为线下班我其实卖的不是课程本身
而且我课程更新换代的非常快
线下班我其实产品的价值除了课程以外还还在于陪跑和指导啊
他怎么去他怎么去盗版呢对吧盗版不了
线上的课程怎么上课上课的话就是我在线下授课的时候我会直接开直播
然后你可以在线看也可以看课程的回放然后指导的话
比如说老师线
线上讲的时候让练习你就暂停一下然后自己做做完了之后发曲里面让老师直接一对一指导就可以了
其实我们是多个老师对你一个指导的
这个你要比线下同学还幸福线下同学幸福的点在于他能让老师现场给他看细节
线上同学的幸福的点在于有好多个老师
围着你转啊
OK线下同学他就没有好多老师围着他转了因为当天是谁上课就是哪个老师围着他转
是这样的
英语一记经典的广告词总结抄袭者有人模仿我的脸还要抄袭我的脸
是的很讨厌啊
然后我说一下我们
这个广告视频大家自己
去要这个链接自己看嘛我这就不播了今天有点晚我有点累啊大家自己去要这个链接看我现场就不播了
然后说到这个
这个视频就是胡同里的苹果
然后这个同学今天
他联系我了说有一个
客户啊让他随便报能报多少人家都接受那种
看上这条视频了他有点不太想卖因为这个是他做的他爸爸的故事他有点不想把这个卖出去但是确实就看上了
反正大家做的东西就是这种品质的啊不是那种简简单单的诚挚啊
你要做诚挚的话我都觉得现在
你都可以自学一下是吧
OK
好那么我们可以来看一下就是我们的学习权益啊这个后面是陪跑180天然后我是想给你们看那个地址在哪来的
在这
上课的地址是在杭州市上城区台湖数字大厦
语翻AI的总部上课时间是8月10号的早晨9点正式开明啊
然后我来说一下就是我们是不包吃包住的
这个我说一下为什么不这样因为这东西羊毛出在羊身上大家都是成年人了是吧
我如果给你包吃包住证明我在这两件事里还要挣你一份钱我觉得就大可不必了
都是成年人也不是小朋友了啊那大家来了之后我们在这个
上城区
在东站的就杭州高铁站的一公里之内
周围全都是
公寓
全都是宾馆
全都是好吃的
所以大家可以随随便便找到住的地方我们相同的一个楼上是有公寓的
私人间最便宜的一天只要30多块钱你自己找就可以了我们可以帮你对接一下但是绝对不会在这个里面是挣大家的钱了就没有任何的意思了是吧搞教育还要挣人家一份住宿钱啊
就大可不必了
学完之后有项目给你们做吗没有
在我这听不到那种什么包派单包项目我来说一下为什么没有啊
其实也是有的但是我不承诺这个东西为啥呢因为
你学的特别好我主动就会找你的我不需要现在把这个当做一个卖客的噱头
明白吧如果你学的特别好我这刚好有很多很好的项目我会主动找你让你去做
如果你
每天上课不做作业
我现在承诺你这个东西你觉得有用吗
没有用的比如上课你不做作业然后那个
天天逃课是吧我承诺你这个东西完全没有用完全没有用
还有一点就是我现在不接任何低价的城市
对我来说没有意义
就是对于我来说啊同学们为啥我说咱们这个365的这个课我属于公益在做
是因为对我来说这个没什么就真的是没什么这个钱
因为我的自媒体账号接一条广告
就已经10个W了啊我真的是没有必要说我我再去接一个
这个一分钟800块钱的单子再介绍给你我也没有这个时间我没有这个精力你可以理解吧就是我确实没有办法给大家去派那种
非常廉价的单子我也不太建议我的学生去做这种廉价的单子
但是我能做到的是我要说但是了哈就可能同学听到这啊我走了你都不给我派单
我想我重点在后半句呢但是我能做到的是
你学完这套课最低标准是能找到工作
你找工作肯定比接单赚钱吧同学们
然后还有一个进阶的标准进阶的目标就是做出自媒体做出自媒体你还用我给你派单吗你的自己的单子都接不完因为我给你派单
我自己的账号能这样变现那我给把我的方法交给你的
现在就承论你派单的全都是纯片子
全都是纯片子
我给你们分析一下为什么我说他们是纯片子的这个逻辑啊因为我是经历过这些东西的我知道我给你们分析下底层逻辑是啥
比如说他接到一个一手单而且是一个精品剧一分钟是在1500到3500左右便宜点的最便宜最便宜的精品剧
也在850以上对吧
那么如果他接的是精品剧首先他是不敢给把精品剧随随便便派给学生的
他派给你了客户给了他定金也给了他一个deadline给他一个交接的时间然后学生没做好
他在交不了差还要赔违约金
他如果接到了一个特别便宜单子他给你他又不挣钱
那最后的结果就是
他其实就是干嘛呢
他其实就是把你骗到群里之后就没有然后了然后给你派一个150一分钟的你爱接不接
基本上那种包排单都是这种状态我这种事我肯定是不会去干的明白吧
大家有其他问题没有我就下了
不搞那种东西哈大可不必
就真的你做的很好我会主动给你的不需要你你问我
对吧
行然后大家还有其他的问题吗
现在AI如果你把我们的课学完之后找工作还是非常容易的
就是你可以要走这个
看一下学员作品
你找那个助理老师看吧因为每一个都蛮长的
你找助理老师看一下每一个都蛮长的然后你直接把这个链接要走
你就打开看把这个链接直接要走去看就可以了
行吧
线上都是学四周线上的话
可能是会有一些自由度的
就比方说你刚好这四周你能脱产学的话你就可以跟着线下的同学一起同步学
如果你不能脱产学有的人
就是白天要上班了那你四周你肯定学不完呀因为我们白天一讲至少要讲四五个小时吧
那你肯定学不完的
学不完的话你就每天给自己规划两个小时的学习时间
看回放
然后做做业找老师指导就可以了
四周之后当然有陪跑了陪跑180天呀
180天哦
对介绍家老师
刚才应该介绍差不多了
前三位都给你们说过了这个第1个是我
然后第2个是大宝老师
跑男王牌
嗨放派
风味春晚
标杆级的
全案指导老师
大宝
这个你们到时候上他的课就知道了你会很震惊的
超强的网感秀局
现在我们正在做的
现在是保密状态啊
我们正在做的我们自己的一个媒体的账号也是大宝老师在
掌控全局
然后呢乐余老师常年的
TVC广告执行导演
三文老师是非常厉害的
应该有个同学加了三文老师的微信了对吧
你们可能以为他是一个课程顾问其实不是的
他只是顺手在当在做课程顾问而已
三文老师是一个非常厉害的自媒体金牌操盘手
他亲手操盘过知识付费赛道的第六名
然后第六名的直播间
就之前贾姐的那个贾姐那个直播间的话术是三文老师一句一句给他写的
然后三文老师一点一点给他打的就是完全是三文老师给他操盘出来的这个直播间
然后还有大钱来了的直播间
然后还有当时我们做的那个大钱来了的投流信息流广告我们做到了行业S级第一名
也是三文老师一手打造出来的非常厉害的金牌操盘手
包括我的账号里的很多的方向都是和三文老师一起讨论出来的
然后三文老师这两个名字还挺像是吧
三文老师之前是字节跳动的商业化专家
然后如果大家想去做一些开发性的东西或者是
找工作做作品集写简历啊都可以找三文老师帮你们去看一下
非常厉害他是一个非常厉害的
大厂的leader啊然后呢能他参与的面试做过面试官的面试
不不少于100场啊所以他
这一点是非常厉害的包括现在对于AI的应用
他应该是全中国在UX设计师当中排到前15的
排到前15的全国啊
能守错90分钟AI电影的太可以了肯定是可以的陪跑是每天布置作业吗当然每天布置作业了每天可能都不止布置一个作业
每天都会有作业的就是线下同学
陪跑啊陪跑是没有每天布置作业陪跑是啥意思同学就是
你课程学完了之后咱就不会再讲课了明白18天以后不会再讲课了
就18天以后干啥呢18天以后你要做自媒体
你每做一篇帖子或者每做一个短视频
选题
脚本
分镜
然后还有你的成片可以一个一个来找我过
就我会陪伴你这180天
不管你是找工作也好还是做自媒体也好我们都会陪伴你让你去不断的有人去给你指导给你赋能
陪跑咱们的这个线下班是小群服务同学
就是我们所有的老师围着你一个人转
哪怕你线下来学学是大家坐在一个教室里学我们一期不会超过25个人就是线下坐在这儿的同学
超过25个人就直接轮换到下一期去学因为我们要保证课程质量不会搞那种大大大大大炒锅那感觉啊
不会搞那个那感觉都是
目前为止所有同学全部都跟上了
只有一个同学跟的慢一点但是他也做完了
就是我们的第3期有一个同学他是不会打字
就不会用电脑不会打字
只有这一个人做的作业他是其他同学都是在学习过程当中全部做完的
目前为止四期已经结束只有一个这一个同学是在学习
学习完后的两个星期做完作业的
想搞自媒体
可以的
你就算是兼职搞你也得拿出大块的时间啊这个我要提前跟你说就是如果你说每天就想半个小时搞个自媒体搞不了搞不了一点
你每天
你要记住一句话就是你的精力在哪里你挣的钱就在哪里就这么简单
就这么简单同学们就是你看我现在我的账号每个月变现也特别好
但是我是不是还在苦哈哈的在讲公开课呀
我是不是还苦哈哈的在介绍我的产品呀
没有一个钱是好挣的
所有的钱都是不好挣的
只是说咱们很辛苦咱尽量能多挣一点是吧咱别辛苦了半天一点没登到
你自己开公司你说了算
可以每一期都有老板这一期老板没那么多这期老板有三分之一上期老板有一半
然后每一期这一期好像还真没有上期和上上期都有现场有一个一些一部分同学把另一部分同学给招聘走的
这期好像还真没有
这期老板相对少一点
上期老板特别多
对大家还有其他问题吗
没问题多少就下了
想看作业的我就不现场放了你们找中小时节要要走这个链接后面一堆作业想怎么看怎么看然后还有
后面放了这应该都是第
三期和第二期的作业还有一些第一期的
第四期的刚结束然后还在我这个U盘里呢还没考没没有给他放上去这一期的会更好一些
慢剧TVC都教
慢剧2D慢剧3D慢剧
TVC
MV真人短剧只要现在用得到的全部都会教的
以前做3D模型想转行做AI非常有优势
你甚至可以使用codex控制你的模型
去做3D动画
我最近也在研究这个
打算做一些教程
然后做3D模型的你还特别适合做IP
小蘑菇秃秃
我最近在研究这个IP我自己要做
但我做的不是这种可爱风的
我买了一个特别的可爱
它是一个数字生命啊正好在我的
广告里插播一点别人的广告
没有收广告费啊
我就是单纯的太喜欢了
然后你看啊这个手机上它有数字生命
然后可以实时的看到你买的这个玩偶在干什么
太好玩了啊
就是它这个商业模式做的非常棒
你们如果说
想想做IP的你就可以
参照一下这个小蘑菇兔兔的一个
营销的路线
它是先走
它的就是很轻量化的视频
然后后面出了盲盒
这个盲盒不是普通的盲盒
它是一个数字生命
就是你可以下载它的APP之后
你实时的看到这个小玩意儿它在干什么
特别可爱
而且永远不是重复的那种
非常有意思
对小蘑菇兔兔我买了一个
我还咱再买一个
你也喜欢这个是吧
行 大家有其他的问题吗
没有的话我就下咯
然后详细的想报名的同学可以找一下助理老师去详细的问一下
我们下一期是8月10号
一般封班我们会提前一个星期左右就封班了
因为人差不多就满了
这一期我们
我们第4期人就满了
然后第5期大概率还是会满
因为现在是暑假也会有一些
刚毕业的学生或者快毕业的学生过来
7月8月会比较的容易满
所以大家尽快的
最好是早一点报
数字人IP是一个套吗
不一样哦
他这个是一个数字生命
他让你真让你觉得他这个IP是个活的
太可爱了
下一期几号
下一期就是这
等8月10号的这一期
那就是9
你说的是9月的吗
9月就是这一期结束了之后往后挪两周左右
就会再开下一期
你说下一期是8月10号
我说的是再下下期
那还暂时还没有定
就是8月10号这一期再结束了再过两周
我们得休息一下
中间隔一周的话有点扛不住
第3期和第2期之间就
第4期和第3期之间就隔了一周
我差点给累死
然后
了解我同学都知道
我从那天一直咳嗽到了
差不多两天前
整整咳嗽了一个多月
我都快绝望了
我都以为自己得肺结核了
刚好
所以这几天在狂喝水
讲课在狂喝水
每个月都有吗
每个月都不一定
因为我们加了编剧课之后
就站线拉长了一点
可能会有偶尔一两个月会中隔过去
应该是每个月都有
不出意外会每个月都有
我的建议就是如果你是非科班啊
一定要早点学
科班的
你现在学以后学都可以
不是科班的
一定要早点学啊
因为给非科班人的时间不多了
时间窗口不多了
咱现在要做的是赶紧
赶紧加三加到这个行里去
赶紧加进去
早进早挣钱
这不是
不是那个营销
营销话术啊
这是
真的
是个大实话
你不用问我问GPT就知道了
你就说我现在是非科班的
你建议我什么时候赶紧进入到AI这个行业
AI影视这个行业当中比较好
他一定会告诉你如何走越好
嗯
还有问题吗
没问题
倒计数十个数准备下了
十
九
哎呀小萝卜兔兔人家说
八
七
还有问题吗
自媒体和短剧哪个好做
那肯定是制作好做呀
自媒体需要坚持的
啊自媒体是需要坚持的
你如果要全制作自媒体你至少要准备两到三个月的生活成本啊
千万别这个把钱全花光了然后说老师我没有钱生活了我怎么做
你要准备两个月生活成本的
要不然做不了啊
短期和TVC哪个哪个赚钱
呃单纯从这个项目来说一定是TVC赚钱
没有任何选念TVC赚钱
ok
行那咱们就先到这里了
倒计是重新开始
就不重新开始了
好咱们先到这了大家如果带有其他的问题可以问一下咱们的那个课程库问老师
一般接单子有什么渠道
渠道就是自己做自媒体客户就会主动来给你单子
就这么简单
那些所谓的给你派单子全是骗子
因为现在的单子
这么跟大家说
你在半年前如果有人跟你说派单子那有可能是真的好单子
现在这个时候有人跟你说单子那绝对把你当努力用不用想绝对就把你当努力用
不用听什么谁谁派单子派不了一点
贵一点的单子
普通人
不一定都做得了
然后呢这个差一点的单子你又不愿意接
没有必要
系统里的内容会包社群和系统它是不一样的同学系统课我是教你底层逻辑让你能够自如的去原创的
能明白这个道理吧
社群课是讲案例的比如说今天我们教的TVC
简单的一个制作
明天咱们教一个LibTV的导演台怎么去使用它是碎片化的东西系统课的话
它肯定是包含以往的内容的呀
就是你学系统课你自己
甚至都能做套课出来
说的夸张一点因为我在自媒体的这节课的时候看我会教你做知识付费类的内容的
你甚至都能自己做套课出来
明白吧
需不需要自己做一工作室不需要你有一个卧室就可以了自己在家我刚当博主的时候我就自己在家当博主的呀
我刚当博主的时候我很慌的我那时候刚刚辞掉了工作
那突然从打工到不打工很慌的
那我哪敢自己花大价钱去租工作室啊这都是一点点来的我是真的经历过OPC过程的
就一人公司的过程的
小红书抖音战裤对
芯片厂
3D访真人剧可以学吗当然可以了
我们会有的自己做工作室然后宣传接广接单
做自媒体
不要想那些什么投流什么的就好好的做自然流做自媒体自己
冲死了头点抖架就可以了
嗯自己居家办公不一定比上班更舒服
不一定哦
自己干压力老大了同学们自己干是007你给别人打工是996
那肯定996或者是朝九晚6更舒服呀
自己干的话挣得多但是你会累死的
我现在就是累死了呀
我刚好了啊我那个
病刚好了
我上个月真的很累的别
光光看见这个贼分招没见贼挨打是吧
你挣得越多你必然越累但是
咱能做到的就是学点好的技能能让自己累
还能拿到结果你别累了半天
只能勉强糊口那就很难受了是吧
想干就干想休息就休息你若是一个个人的话就可以做到这样
但如果你像我一样我是有公司那就休息根本休息不了一点
休息不了一点的
朝九晚十
太惨了吧
我的团队我们都是六点下班的
而且还双休我们在杭州非常罕见
非常罕见的一个公司
我对我嗓子咳嗽好久了
我今天才刚刚突然这一天咳的少了
我觉得还是蛮震惊的我今天突然咳的少了
就今天开始了
3D仿真剧市场大吗
嗯这个问题问的就有点
不专业同学啊
我跟大家说哈
就是别问我是3D仿真剧市场大吗
真人剧市场大吗
你说的这叫表现形式
市场大不大取决于你的选题怎么样
取决于你的剧本怎么样
取决于你的营销方式
和你的宣传
宣传方式怎么样
取决于你的剧本身好不好
跟你是不是什么形式没关系
那宫崎骏
现在还做2D呢
那不照样拿奥斯卡
拿日本的票房冠军吗
跟这没关系同学
不要不要流于形式
不要流于形式
为啥我要在第四周加一个编剧呀
很多人觉得这玩意有啥用啊
是吧
我学会制作就行了
如果我是个割韭菜的一个老师我肯定不加这一星期的课
因为你前面学完了你已经做的很炫了你开开心就走了
你只会在半年一年之后突然发现我我我现在不会写剧本我有点难受是吧
但是如果如果我不负责的话我直接我就我就不会加这个部分
当然如果半年前你确实不需要加这个部分但是现在AI谁生成的都已经很好了
大家拼的是什么拼的是本子
对编剧是基础
行
那就到这里吧
嗯不聊喽
拜拜同学们
拜拜
我这起了个泡
感觉
晚安
关了啊